Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Ulf. Ja, Logbuch Netzpolitik, Folge 112. Die 112 und der Tim ist nicht da. Der ist im Urlaub. Wie ihr alle wisst, das hat er ja schon angekündigt und ich habe mir jetzt dann überlegt, ich reagiere auf die Kritik, die wir erfahren haben aufgrund unserer mangelnden Kompetenz in Fragen der Juristerei. Und es wurde ja mehrfach in den Kommentaren angeregt, wir mögen uns doch mal einen Anwalt reinholen. Aber einen Anwalt kommt natürlich bei Logbuch Netzpolitik nicht in Frage. Es muss dann schon ein Richter sein. Und der Richter musste erst aus den USA eingeflogen werden. Und das ist Ulf Buermeyer.
Genau, hallo Linus.
Es gibt ja ein schönes Küchenradio mit dir, wo du von deiner Zeit in den USA erzählt hast. Das empfehlen wir natürlich und verlinken es in den Shownotes. Und wir müssen dich deswegen nicht erklären, warum du auf der deutschen netzaktivistischen Szene in den letzten 18 Monaten, die man dich kaum noch gesehen hat, wie lange warst du denn weg eigentlich?
Also weg war ich eigentlich ziemlich genau zwölf Monate. Es fehlte eigentlich nur eine Woche. Aber in der letzten Zeit vorher habe ich einfach noch so ein paar Projekte zu Ende gebracht.
So eine Promotion?
Genau. Ich habe insbesondere meine Diss zu Ende geschrieben. Und natürlich ist so ein Umzug in die USA mit einigen Vorbereitungen verbunden. Also das ist eher eine Untertreibung in dem Podcast mit Philipp Banzer. Und Andi habe ich das auch noch ein bisschen genauer erklärt, wie viel Vorbereitung da eigentlich dazugehörte, um da in die USA gehen zu können. Insofern bin ich so ein bisschen abgetaucht, seit vielleicht dem Anfang 2013.
Und bekannt bist du, glaube ich, hauptsächlich durch, einmal natürlich, weil wir beide beim 29C3 zusammen mit Markus Beckethal auf der Bühne standen. Das war ja auch ein großer Moment, aber wahrscheinlich eher durch deine Arbeit in Fragen des Staatstrojaners, denke ich.
Genau, ich habe damals mit dem CCC zusammen quasi die Analyse gemacht für den Staatstrojaner, den wir in Bayern gefunden hatten. Die PR eigentlich haben Frank und Constanze vor allem gemacht, aber ich hatte ihnen quasi die juristische Analyse zugeliefert. Das war natürlich sehr schön. Wir haben das hinterher auch wunderbar noch, denke ich, ausgewertet auf dem Kongress. Zwei Mal sogar, also erst quasi unmittelbar den Trojaner vorgestellt und dann ein Jahr später so ein bisschen, was die Politik daraus gemacht hat, uns nochmal kritisch angesehen. Genau, das war so ziemlich das Erste, was ich mit dem CCC in der Öffentlichkeit gemacht habe.
Warst du damals eigentlich auch schon Richter?
Ja, ich bin schon seit 2007 Richter. Also der Staatskongrenator war ja 2011, da war ich auch schon eine ganze Weile dabei. Richtig.
Und zieht sich das für einen Richter?
Interessanterweise habe ich noch von niemandem Kritik gehört. Nun mag es natürlich sein, dass solche Dinge dann auch nicht offen gesagt werden, sondern dass da getuschelt wird. Aber wenn ich Feedback bekommen habe, war das eigentlich immer eher anerkennend und auch nicht nur von Freunden. Man muss ja sehen, was der CCC macht, ist im Grunde der wahre Verfassungsschutz. In diesem Fall war ja die interessante Besonderheit, dass die bayerische Polizei in krassester Weise über die Stränge geschlagen war. Und der CCC hat einfach aufgedeckt, dass Staatsdiener eben alles andere taten als dem Staat zu dienen. Die haben letzten Endes die Grundlagen unseres Staates, denke ich, unterhöhlt. Jedenfalls in diesem Einzelfall, indem sie illegale Software eingesetzt haben, ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste. Und insofern hat der CCC letzten Endes dazu beigetragen, dass sich die bayerische Polizei wieder an Recht und Gesetz hält. Und ich denke, dazu einen Beitrag zu leisten, das zieht sich natürlich auch für einen Richter. Ich will das jetzt nicht so hochhängen, aber...
Als jemand, der an der Sache ja nicht beteiligt war, muss ich schon sagen, das war eine sehr international einmalige Sache, dass eine Bürgerrechtsgruppierung, eine Hackergruppe hingeht, eine Software-Analysisch macht, das Ganze irgendwie mit einem relativ großen Medien-Coup veröffentlicht, das Ganze bis zum Ende durch, exerziert hat eben mit professionellem juristischen Rat. Also so eine Aktion ist ja schon auch wirklich, die gelingt einem ja echt sehr, sehr selten.
Ja, das war wirklich ein großes Glück. Und da muss man einfach sagen, da kann man immer nur wieder diesem Anwalt danken, dem Verteidiger dieses Mannes, dem die bayerische Polizei, den Trojaner auf die Festplatte gespielt hatte, Patrick Schlaert. Und der war einfach auf Draht. Der hatte mich damals einige Monate vor der Veröffentlichung einfach angerufen. Ich hatte einen Aufsatz geschrieben an der juristischen Fachzeitschrift über Staatstrojaner und der hat mich angerufen und sagte, Herr Buermeyer, sagen Sie mal, ich habe da in der Akte diese CD gefunden. Da sind 50.000 Screenshots drauf. Wo kommen die denn her? Wo kommen die wohl her? 50.000 Screenshots von dem Laptop meines Mandanten. Und ich sage, Herr Schlaert, jetzt muss ich mich erst mal setzen. Ich glaube, da haben Sie einen ganz dicken Fisch an der Angel. Und der sagte, ja, ganz heißes Eis. Ganz heißes Eis. Und dann sagte er, ja, aber der eigentliche Knaller kommt noch. Ich hole morgen den Laptop wieder ab. Das heißt also, er wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt schon, dass das Bayerische LKA den Laptop freigeben würde. Und daraufhin haben wir dann vereinbart, also bitte nur mit ganz spitzen Fingern anfassen, das gute Stück. Bloß nicht fallen lassen. Ich kenne da ein paar Leute, die würden sich den gerne mal genauer ansehen. Und so ist das zustande gekommen. So ist das zustande gekommen. Und in der Tat würde ich auch sagen, das war wahrscheinlich der größte Beitrag, den der CCC quasi zur Rechtsstaatlichkeit in unserem Land geleistet hat. Der CCC macht ja seit vielen Jahren sehr gute Arbeit. Aber quasi mal den Sumpf der illegalen Staatstrojaner auszutrocknen, das war, denke ich, ein ziemlicher Move. Und ja, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, ich glaube, das ist natürlich völlig okay. Das ist aus meiner Sicht Kern meines Jobs, eben für unsere Verfassung einzutreten, auch wenn es nicht allen Ministern gerade den Kram passen mag.
Und du bist aber auch natürlich eigentlich in einer Situation, in der du ja Richter für Strafrecht bist.
Ganz genau.
An welchem Gericht können wir bei der Gelegenheit direkt den ersten Lerneffekt?
Ich bin am Landgericht Berlin, seit 2008 inzwischen. Und dort jetzt gerade wieder, seit Anfang August, in einer sogenannten Spurgerichtskammer. Das ist aber im Grunde ein alter Zopf. Das ist einfach eine große Strafkammer. Also eine Kammer mit drei Kollegen, einem Vorsitzenden, einer Beisitzerin und meiner Wenigkeit. Und die heißt nur deswegen Spurgerichtskammer, weil wir zuständig sind für Mord und Totschlag. Also Fälle, wo jemand vorsätzlich zu Tode gekommen ist. Und da gab es bis in die 20er Jahre auch in Deutschland Gesporene. Und damals hieß das eben Spurgericht wegen der Gesporenen. Und diese Bezeichnung hat sich einfach erhalten. Aber das ist im Prinzip eine ganz normale Kammer.
Und wenn man sich entscheidet für den Weg durch die Instanzen, dann fängt man am Landgericht an?
Genau, das ist natürlich wie alles in der Juristerei ein bisschen kompliziert. Es kommt drauf an. Aber in Strafsachen ist es so, wenn es eine kleine Sache ist, dann wird die zum Amtsgericht angeklagt. Und wenn es eine größere Sache ist, dann zum Landgericht.
Amtsgericht, Landgericht und dann?
Wenn es am Amtsgericht losgeht, dann gibt es danach die Berufung zum Landgericht und dagegen noch mal die Revision zum Oberlandesgericht oder in Berlin zum Kammergericht. Und wenn es gleich beim Landgericht losgeht, so zum Beispiel eben in den Fällen, in denen ich beruflich tätig bin, dann ist die nächste Instanz der Bundesgerichtshof. Das heißt, dann kann man Revision einlegen und dann entscheidet der Bundesgerichtshof, ob die berechtigt ist.
Okay, dann haben wir jetzt quasi die Hierarchie der Gerichte ist Amt, Land, Oberlandes, Bundesgericht.
Ganz genau, Bundesgerichtshof.
Bundesgerichtshof. Wunderbar. Dann haben wir das geklärt, weil wir immer dann häufigerweise die Frage hatten, gegen das Unterkann Revision eingelegt werden. Ja, wo denn jetzt überhaupt? Geht das jetzt zum EuGH oder kommt da vorher nochmal?
Nee, das ist komplex. Und ich meine, es gibt ja manchmal gibt es eine Berufung und manchmal gibt es eine Revision. Das ist also schon...
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen...
Eine Berufung bedeutet im Wesentlichen, dass der ganze Fall nochmal neu aufgerollt wird. Im Strafrecht bedeutet das, dass der Fall wirklich, also der wird im Prinzip komplett neu verhandelt. Während eine Revision bedeutet, dass man ganz bestimmte Kritik an dem Urteil üben muss. Das heißt also, das Revisionsgericht rollt den Fall gerade nicht komplett neu auf, sondern es liest das Urteil und das Protokoll der Hauptverhandlung. Und dann liest es die Revisionsbegründung und die Erwiderung von der anderen Seite. Und dann entscheidet es nur anhand dieses Papiers, ob an der Revision was dran ist. Das heißt also, da muss man ganz konkret das Urteil kritisieren, wegen bestimmter Fehler, können Verfahrensfehler sein zum Beispiel. Und nur wenn das Revisionsgericht aufgrund dieser Unterlagen bestimmte Fehler identifizieren kann, nur dann hebt es das Urteil teilweise auf und verweist es zurück. Und in ganz großen Ausnahmefällen kann es auch selber entscheiden. Aber meistens bedeutet das nur, dass das Urteil quasi an bestimmten Punkten oder auch komplett aufgehoben wird und dann noch mal neu verhandelt werden muss von der Instanz darunter.
Was wäre jetzt so ein üblicher Verfahrensfehler, den man da, also was wäre jetzt so ein klassischer?
Ein Klassiker, was ganz häufig schief geht, sind Verletzungen zum Beispiel des Anwesenheitsrechts des Angeklagten. Also es gibt in der Strafprozessordnung den Grundsatz, dass der Angeklagte im Prinzip da sein muss. Er hat also ein Recht auf Anwesenheit, aber auch eine Pflicht zur Anwesenheit. Und dann gibt es aber bestimmte Gründe, wo der Angeklagte aus dem Saal verwiesen werden kann. Also der Klassiker wäre zum Beispiel eine Strafverhandlung wegen einer Vergewaltigung. Da möchte man es dem mutmaßlichen Opfer normalerweise nicht zumuten, dass der Vergewaltiger zwei Meter weiter sitzt. Und in diesen Fällen kann dann zum Beispiel die Kammer den Angeklagten für die Dauer der Vernehmung dieser Zeugin, ist sehr typischerweise eine Zeugin, aus dem Saal schicken. Aber dann gibt es noch die Frage, wird die Zeugin vereidigt? Und während die Kammer sich darüber in eine Meinung bildet, ob die Zeugin vereidigt werden muss oder vereidigt werden soll, während dieser Zeit zum Beispiel, da muss normalerweise der Angeklagte schon wieder im Saal sein. Da gibt es also ganz große Feinheiten. Und wenn da was schiefgeht, oder wenn zum Beispiel die Zeugin dann noch mal ein bisschen ergänzend vernommen werden soll, noch eine Frage, und dann schickt man den Angeklagten einfach so wieder raus, nachdem er schon wieder im Saal war. Das geht nicht, da muss man einen neuen Beschluss treffen. Also im Kontext von Anwesenheitsrechten, da passieren einfach unglaublich schnell Verfahrensfehler. Und das wäre so ein Fall, wo dann war das einfach ein zwingender Revisionsgrund, ist ein sogenannter absoluter Revisionsgrund, dann müsste der Bundesgerichtshof das Urteil aufheben. Auch wenn das Urteil sonst 100 Seiten lang ist und komplett in Ordnung.
Schön, dass wir auch da dann den Weg der Bürokratie uns offen halten können.
Das muss man sagen. Das klingt sehr bürokratisch und es ist offensichtlich auch nicht so ganz einfach, manchmal zu verstehen, warum dann so ein Urteil aufgehoben werden muss. Aber auf der anderen Seite, gerade diese absoluten Revisionsgründe, wo also nicht mehr geguckt werden kann, hat sich dieser Fehler ausgewirkt, sondern wo der Fehler automatisch dazu führt, dass das Urteil aufgehoben wird. Diese absoluten Gründe schützen eben ganz wichtige Grundsätze unseres Prozessrechts. Das Anwesenheitsrecht des Angeklagten ist schon ganz wesentlich einfach, weil der nicht nur ein Objekt des Verfahrens sein soll, es soll nicht etwas mit ihm geschehen, sondern er soll Subjekt sein. Er soll sich eben verteidigen können, er soll mitbekommen, was da im Saal eigentlich geschieht. Insofern ist das zwar bitter im Einzelfall und kostet natürlich auch viel Geld, wenn also eine komplette Hauptverhandlung neu durchgeführt werden muss, aber ich denke, im Kern ist das schon richtig. Und da muss man dann eben als Gericht aufpassen. Das sind ja Fehler, die können vermieden werden. Da muss man dann eben einfach genau aufpassen.
Da muss man wissen, was der Job, den man macht, von einem erfordert.
Ganz genau. Ja, aber ich will jetzt nicht darüber lästern, das kann schnell passieren, aber ich denke, da muss nicht das Recht geändert werden, sondern da muss man als Richter oder als Richterin, wie auch immer, seinen Job machen.
Okay, so viel zu der Frage deiner Kompetenz. Wir werden dich dann in Zukunft öfter mal zum Suchen von Verfahrensfehlern heranziehen, weil es ja ab und zu auch mal Urteile gibt, die uns nicht so gut gefallen, beim Logbuch. Aber wir hatten eine sehr, sehr ereignisreiche letzte Woche und wollen natürlich so ein bisschen über diese Geschehnisse sprechen. Ich habe die jetzt, normalerweise sortiere ich die immer noch mal nach Priorität, aber ich glaube, wir gehen sie einfach mal so ein bisschen der Reihenfolge durch. Die CIA hat zugegeben, dass sie ihr eigenes parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium überwacht hat.
Kann man machen, muss man aber nicht.
Kann man machen?
Nein, kann man sicherlich nicht machen.
Also die CIA ist ja vielleicht, um die ganzen Geheimdienste der USA mal so aufzuklären, oder zumindest die CIA einmal von der NSA zu unterscheiden. Die CIA ist ja nicht im Massenüberwachungsbusiness, sondern kümmert sich eher um so gezielte Operationen und Folter.
Das sind ja so die Black Sides, die Folterkeller weltweit, nur nicht in den USA. Also die CIA ist von der ursprünglichen Mission quasi der Auslandsgeheimdienst. Central Intelligence Agency, das heißt, die Mission ist Auslandsaufklärung mit dem Ziel, diplomatische Vorteile zu erzielen und gegebenenfalls auch irgendwelche Kriegsgefahren rechtzeitig zu erkennen, die Interessen der USA weltweit zu schützen. Aber eigentlich haben sie keine Mission im Inland. Das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit unserem BND, der ja bei uns der Auslandsgeheimdienst ist. Und die CIA darf eigentlich im Inland überhaupt gar nicht tätig werden. Das heißt also, es ist natürlich ein ganz besonderer Skandal, wenn die jetzt ausgerechnet den Ausschuss anzapfen, der sich mit der CIA beschäftigt und sie theoretisch kontrollieren soll. Aber es ist auch schon ein Skandal, dass sie überhaupt im Inland tätig waren.
Das sollten sie eigentlich auch nicht tun. Aber auch im Ausland ist die CIA jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt, nur Leute zu foltern, sondern ja auch schon mindestens seit 50, 60 Jahren dort aktiv in den politischen Prozess in anderen Ländern einzugreifen. Also dort, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Aufruhre zu unterstützen, heranzubeschwören oder so. Das sind ja immer auch so diese Aktionen, die der CIA dann zugeschrieben wird.
Ja, so Kommandoaktionen bis hin zur gezielten Tötung irgendwelcher missliebigen Regierungschefs zum Beispiel. Also ich muss gestehen, ich bin jetzt wahrlich kein Spezialist für CIA-Aktionen, aber in der Tat werden die auch gerne mal tätig. Es geht jetzt also nicht nur darum, dass sie lauschen und notieren und fotografieren, sondern die sind auch zuständig für Kommandooperationen.
Für aktive Gestaltung der Politik.
Ja, ganz genau. So gab es jetzt zum Beispiel diesen einen, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das jetzt namentlich war, aber jedenfalls einen, der wurde mal beschrieben als quasi Senior Official irgendwie aus der amerikanischen Intelligence Community, der meinte, naja, also eigentlich sollte die CIA doch mal sehen, ob sie nicht in Moskau Edward Snowden ausfindig macht. Und dann ein kleiner Pieks in den Arm, ja, so malte sich dieser Offizier das aus. Ein kleiner Pieks in den Arm und eine Stunde später wird ihm so schwummrig und er geht duschen und er steht nie mehr auf. Ja, das war so diese, wie soll ich sagen, diese etwas dunkle Fantasie dieses einen Offiziellen, ja, um seine kreative Lösung des Edward Snowden-Problems.
Und schon im März, um da ein bisschen zurückzukommen, beschuldigte die Dianne Feierstein, die CIA, da irgendwie dieses Komitee, das Komitee, also das Senate Intelligence Committee abgehört zu haben und verlangte eine Entschuldigung. Und die CIA reagierte irgendwie natürlich wie Geheimdienste reagieren, irgendwie mit, was, bitte, ne, wir sagen gar nichts, wir können das nicht kommentieren. Und jetzt stellte sich heraus, sie haben das Computernetz, dieses Senate Intelligence Committee infiltriert, während es an einem Bericht über die, über das, wie könnte man das so schön übersetzen, über das Verwahrungs- und Verhörprogramm der CIA verfasst haben. Das CIA Detention and Interrogation Program, das da eben von diesem Kontrollgremium genauer untersucht wurde. Und während das Kontrollgremium daran arbeitete, hat die CIA mit drei Infosec-Experten, Infosec-Experte ist dann in den USA in der Regel der Euphemismus für Hacker und zwei Anwälten, frage ich mich, wie die da mit reingekommen sind, daran gearbeitet, eben sein eigenes Kontrollkomitee zu überwachen. Sie haben Mails gelesen, haben wohl auch versucht, falsche Infos zu verbreiten, dadurch, dass sie irgendwie Zugänge auf deren Mailkonten hatten. Und haben dann Rechner der Mitarbeiter, also der Mitarbeiter der Abgeordneten dort gehackt.
Ja, das ist schon wirklich sehr interessant. Also die New York Times hat das ja auch noch mal so ein bisschen zusammengefasst. Und wenn man das liest, dann muss man also wirklich die Zeilen sicherheitshalber einfach nochmal lesen, weil man das erst gar nicht glaubt. Also wie gesagt, die haben da quasi diese Rechner angezapft. Sie haben aber dann auch noch so verschiedene quasi FUD-Taktiken angewendet. Ja, Fear, Uncertainty and Doubt, quasi Nebelkerzen könnte man vielleicht auf Deutsch sagen. Sie haben nämlich zum Beispiel eine Strafanzeige an das Justizministerium geschickt, auf der Grundlage falscher Informationen, einfach vielleicht um diesem Komitee Probleme zu bereiten. Und außerdem haben sie sich also falsche Online-Identitäten angelegt und unter diesen DEC-Identitäten dann auch noch mal versucht, sich quasi Backdoors anzulegen, also Hintertüren zu diesem Rechnersystem. Das ist schon ein starkes Stück, denn du hast das eben am Rande erwähnt. Es ging eben um dieses Programm der CIA, das Detention and Interrogation Program genannt wird. Aber es geht im Kern darum, dass die CIA in verschiedenen osteuropäischen und auch arabischen Staaten Folterkeller angelegt hat.
Die verschleppen Menschen und foltern sie.
Genau, das muss man sich klar machen. Unter der Bush-Regierung gab es ein systematisches Programm. Da hat die CIA zusammengearbeitet mit privaten Charterluftlinien. Da gab es bestimmte Jets, die regelmäßig für die CIA geflogen sind. Und dann wurden weltweit Menschen verschleppt, in irgendeinen Charterjet gepackt und zu einer Black-Side gefahren. Und dort dann eben detained and interrogated. Das muss man wohl so sagen. Das ist jetzt einige Jahre später auch in den USA zumindest in die Diskussion geraten, dieses Folterprogramm. Und dieses Committee sollte aufarbeiten, was die CIA da eigentlich gemacht hat. Und da haben sich die Jungs von der CIA gedacht, da wollen wir doch lieber genauer wissen, was dabei rauskommt.
Und natürlich, also illegal in jeder Form, ein Verstoß gegen die Gewaltenteilung, das falsche Land. Sie hätten in jedem anderen Land der Welt hätten sie so etwas problemlos machen dürfen.
Aber im eigenen Land?
Im eigenen Land geht das nicht. Also diese Ironie überhaupt, dass du hast da so eine Demokratie, die hat irgendwie ihre parlamentarischen Gremien, die gönnt sich um die Handlungsfähigkeit des Landes im internationalen Konflikt aufrechtzuerhalten. Einen Geheimdienst, der mit allerlei Rechten ausgestattet ist, nämlich keinerlei Gebindung an irgendwelche Gesetze im Ausland, stülpt dem ein Kontrollgremium auf. Und dieses Kontrollgremium greift dieser Geheimdienst dann auch noch an. Das ist wirklich schauderhaft. Und das Schöne war die Reaktion, diese Beschuldigung stand ja schon seit einiger Zeit im Raum. Und da ist dann irgendwie nichts geschehen. Und der Direktor der CIA, der John Brennan, hat sich jetzt freundlich entschuldigt.
Das finden wir aber doch irgendwie ganz nett, oder?
Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Und er hat, was ich aber sehr cool finde, er hat eine Untersuchungskommission eingerichtet. Eine interne CIA-Untersuchungskommission.
Das heißt, da dürfen dann die Praktikanten mal das Lauschen trainieren.
Die CIA geht raus, foltert das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, will darüber ein, will in Erfahrung bringen, was überhaupt stattfindet. Die CIA greift ihr eigenes Kontrollgremium an, entschuldigt sich dann und macht dann eine interne Untersuchungskommission innerhalb der CIA.
Ich bin gespannt, wer die jetzt eigentlich dann angreift oder wer deren Festplatten dann irgendwie über Nacht formatiert.
Die kriegen wahrscheinlich alle einfach nur einen freundlichen Hinweis, dass ihr Arbeitsvertrag ja eigentlich mit sehr schönen Benefits einhergeht und dass sie die doch sicherlich auch behalten möchten.
Vermutlich, genau. Ja, also das ist schon ziemlich krass und dazu muss man wissen, also die Vorsitzende dieses Committees, die Diane Feinstein, ist jetzt also durchaus nicht die Harteste. Die hat also bislang eigentlich vor allem dadurch auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, dass sie dieses Committee in trauter Einigkeit mit der sogenannten Intelligence Community geführt hat. Also die hat bislang diesen Kontrollauftrag im Wesentlichen so verstanden, dass sie den Diensten bescheinigt hat, wie wichtig sie sind, damit sie weiter so viel Geld bekommen wie bisher und im Zweifel noch ein paar Dollar mehr. Also die war jetzt bislang wahrlich keine Speerspitze der Bürgerrechte. Und wenn es der jetzt schon reicht, dann ist das als solches schon wirklich eine Nachricht.
Also das sollte ja nun wirklich jedem reichen. Ich meine, diese ganze Idee der parlamentarischen Kontrolle und Transparenz der Geheimdienste, demokratische Wächter über die Geheimdienstaktivität, das ist ja gerade in diesen Zeiten eine sehr wichtige Forderung, ein sehr wichtiger Diskussionspunkt, auch immer, dass man sagt, wir müssen die demokratische Kontrolle über die Geheimdienste zurückerlangen, weil Edward Snowden uns zeigt, dass wir sie drohen zu verlieren.
Wenn man mal ganz zurückhaltend formulieren will.
Und dann kriegst du so eine Nachricht, die erstaunlicherweise aber auch echt kaum mehr jemanden wirklich zu überraschen scheint. Also es scheint ja jetzt nicht wirklich jemanden schockiert zu haben.
Also ich würde schon sagen, dass es in den USA da einen kleinen Aufschrei gab, zumindest in der liberalen Presse. Also ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass er quasi eine breite öffentliche Diskussion eingesetzt hätte. Mir ist auch keine Demo bekannt, keine Protestdemo, keine Mahnwache oder derlei. Aber das war schon ein Fall, der jedenfalls in der liberalen Presse, zum Beispiel in den New York Times oder mit Abstrichen auch in der Washington Post wirklich einige Tage für Diskussionen gesorgt hat. Auf der anderen Seite sind mir keine Konsequenzen bekannt. Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, für die CIA war das jetzt peinlich, sicherlich, klar. War ein PR-Gau. Aber konkret ist mir nicht bekannt, dass irgendwie Konsequenzen gezogen worden wären.
Wer legt sich auch mit einer Bande an, die irgendwie Menschen verschleppt, foltert und...
Ja, und ich meine, die in Zweifel natürlich über jeden Senator und jeden Representative irgendein Dossier führt. Und ich meine, man kann ja mal so ganz kurz in sich gehen. Ich glaube, die allermeisten Menschen haben irgendwelche Dinge in ihrem Leben jeweils schon mal getan, die sie nicht in der Presse lesen möchten oder die zumindest irgendwie die Ehefrau oder der Ehemann nicht wissen sollte. Also mal ganz vorsichtig formuliert, Menschen, die wirklich nicht erpressbar sind. Im Sinne von, über mich kann jeder alles wissen. Die dürften zumindest seltene Früchtchen sein oder seltene Pflänzchen. Und vor diesem Hintergrund kann es sich vermutlich auch kaum jemand leisten, von den Menschen, die eigentlich zur Kontrolle der Geheimdienste berufen wären, da wirklich mal die Daumenschrauben anzuziehen.
Als ein Mensch mit völlig weißer Weste gelangst du wahrscheinlich auch im Haifischbecken der amerikanischen Politik überhaupt gar nicht erst in diese Position.
Das könnte auch ganz gut sein, ja.
Du hast da noch schön einen Link rausgesucht zur Finanzierung von Dianne Feinstein.
Das ist sehr lustig, ja genau. Das muss man sagen, der amerikanische Kongress ist ja noch in ganz anderer Weise gekauft als die Politik in Deutschland oder andersrum formuliert. Ich denke, dass unser System der Wahlkampf- und Parteienfinanzierung vergleichsweise gut funktioniert. Natürlich gibt es auch bei uns Abhängigkeiten von Spendern. Natürlich gibt es da auch immer wieder insbesondere peinliche Jobwechsel aus der Politik in die Wirtschaft. Quasi so eine Art nachgelagerte Bestechung. Aber das sieht alles in Amerika noch ganz anders aus, weil die dortigen Abgeordneten typischerweise nicht von der Partei ihren Wahlkampf finanziert bekommen, sondern von Spendern. Das heißt, sie müssen einen erheblichen Teil ihrer Arbeitszeit dafür aufwenden, sich ans Telefon zu hängen und irgendwelche Spender anzurufen und auf diese Art und Weise sicherzustellen, dass sie überhaupt wiedergewählt werden. Was natürlich zu Abhängigkeiten führt, ganz offensichtlich, auf der anderen Seite gibt es aber auch immer wieder Versuche, dieses System der Politikerfinanzierung ein wenig transparenter zu machen. Und opensecrets.org ist also eine Seite, die das versucht und die publiziert, das können wir vielleicht in die Shownotes packen, dann eben für Politiker, wer denn eigentlich deren Hauptfinanciers sind. Und wenn man sich das mal für Dianne Feinstein anschaut, dann ist das Interessante, also die Summen sind auch enorm. Also zum Beispiel von 2009 bis 2014 hat sie fast 10 Millionen Dollar Spenden gesammelt. Nicht etwa für die Demokratische Partei, sondern ausschließlich für sich alleine. Und 11,5 Millionen ausgegeben, was dazu führt, dass sie jetzt auch mit knapp 400.000 Dollar momentan in der Kreide steht. Also wie die Differenzen zustande kommen, das arithmetisch geht es ja nicht ganz auf, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, die hat also auch massiv Schulden und da müssen also Spenden reinkommen, sonst wäre sie irgendwann pleite, das wäre ja auch nicht schön. Und dann sind also die Hauptspender aufgeführt, die Top 5 Contributors 2009 bis 2014. Und dort finden sich fünf Firmen und ich bin jetzt wahrlich kein Spezialist für amerikanisches Lobbying, aber zwei Namen stechen hervor, nämlich General Atomics und General Dynamics und das sind zwei Waffenschmieden. Mit anderen Worten, also zwei der fünf wichtigsten Spender kommen aus der Waffenindustrie und die wiederum hat in den Vereinigten Staaten eben typischerweise nicht nur irgendwie mit Panzerbauen zu tun, sondern die haben in der Regel mittlerweile auch Software-Sparten. Also das sind typischerweise Konglomerate, die eben klassische Waffen bauen, aber inzwischen auch eng vernetzte mit der Softwareindustrie und insofern dann wiederum gerne mit der CIA zusammenarbeiten. Das heißt also zwei der fünf Hauptspender haben zumindest enge Beziehungen zur CIA. Da kann man sich vorstellen, woher das eigentlich kommt, dass die gute Diane eben ihr Committee bislang nicht so überkritisch geführt hat. Das ist schon sehr interessant. Es gibt dazu noch andere schöne Texte, die habe ich jetzt auf die Schnelle nicht mehr gefunden. Es gibt also auch da eine intensive journalistische Begleitung. Es gibt schon Leute, denen das aufgefallen war, dass die eben in den letzten Jahren immer alles gesund gebetet hat. Also zum Beispiel nach den Snowden-Enthüllungen gab es ja relativ schnell die ersten Gesetzentwürfe im Senat in den Vereinigten Staaten die Kompetenzen der NSA zu beschneiden. Einer dieser Gesetzentwürfe, der in der Tat relativ radikal gewesen wäre, der ist ganz knapp gescheitert und eine der Hauptopponenten, also Hauptgegnerinnen dieses Gesetzentwurfs, war Diane, weil sie meinte, das geht doch hier viel zu weit und die sind doch schon auch irgendwie wichtig. Lass uns zwar jetzt nicht das Kind mit dem Bart ausschütten. Lass uns den Bart auch mal flach halten. Das muss man sich mal in Ruhe überlegen und ein Committee einsetzen. Und dann reden wir nochmal. Na ja, also wir wollen auch nicht zu zynisch werden, aber ich finde, es wirft so ein schönes Schlaglicht auf die Finanzierung der Abgeordneten im US-Kongress. Und ja, da kann man sich vorstellen, wie Dinge eben laufen.
In Deutschland gab es ein schönes Urteil des BGH.
Ja, in der Tat.
Beziehungsweise ist es wirklich so schön. Es ging um einen, ich versuche das jetzt erstmal wieder in meiner Laiensprache zum Ausdruck zu bringen. Ein Kunde hat gegen die Telekom geklagt, weil sie seine IP-Adresse, also seine IP-Adresse in History gespeichert hat, obwohl er eine Flatrate hat. Ihr wisst ja, man hat selbst bei einer Flatrate wechselnde IP-Adressen. Die wechseln in der Regel einmal alle 24 Stunden. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Einer ist der, dass wir gar nicht mehr genug IP-Adressen haben, um alles gleichzeitig mit dem Internet zu verbinden. Andererseits ist es seit den Ursprungstagen eigentlich so, dass die Provider natürlich auch verhindern möchten, dass wir unter festen IP-Adressen dann zum Beispiel anfangen, Dienste anzubieten oder so. Es hat natürlich auch einen Datenschutzvorteil, wenn sich unsere IP-Adressen regelmäßig ändern. Denn dann sind wir nicht dauerhaft für naive Beobachter markierbar. Das heißt also, jeden Tag, wenn ich blogfefe.de aufrufe, dann kann man zunächst nicht mit einfachen Mitteln erkennen, dass es wieder ich bin, weil sich meine IP-Adresse geändert hat. Und das ist eigentlich etwas, was natürlich von, sage ich mal, fortgeschrittenen Internetnutzern auch gerne mal bemängelt wird, dass sich diese IP-Adressen unnötigerweise ändern, von Datenschützern aber auch sehr hochgehalten wird, dass sich diese IP-Adressen eben zufällig rotieren und wir nicht dauerhaft identifizierbar sind. Und der Kunde hat also gesagt, wenn ich eh eine Flatrate habe, das heißt, ihr für meine gesamte Internetnutzung, unabhängig von dem, was ich wirklich tue, einen Betrag erlangt, dann braucht ihr auch keine Abrechnungsdaten darüber aufzubewahren und erst recht nicht meine IP-Adresse. Denn hier überwiegt ja offensichtlich das Anliegen des Datenschutzes. Und die Telekom konnte dann vor Gericht glaubhaft machen, dass sie die Daten zumindest vorübergehend braucht für ihr eigenes Debugging bei Störungen, dass sie Störungen beseitigen können. Und natürlich der Hintergrund der ganzen Sache ist für Anfragen der Polizei nach, welche IP-Adresse, wann welchem Nutzer zugeordnet war, um das dann auch im Rahmen der Strafverfolgung zu nutzen, was hier aber bei diesem Verfahren glaube ich niemals so wirklich ausgesprochen wurde, wobei das natürlich eigentlich der pinke Elefant im Raum war. Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Ja, ich glaube, das kann man so sagen. Es gibt natürlich auch Ausnahmen von dieser dynamischen IP-Zuweisung. Gerade Kabelprovider weisen immer noch gerne feste IPs zu. Ich kabel Deutschland zum Beispiel. Jedenfalls solange du deinen Kabelmodem nicht rebootest, eigentlich eine feste IP. Aber gut, die Telekom macht das bei ihren DSL-Anschlüssen zum Beispiel, wie du genau das beschrieben hast. Der Witz dabei ist, dass es ja nun eben keine Vorschriften mehr zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt. Schon in Deutschland, nicht seit das Bundesverfassungsgericht die konkrete Umsetzung abgeschossen hat. Jetzt wird es so schnell auch wahrscheinlich keine Neuregelung mehr geben. Denn der Europäische Gerichtshof hat ja jetzt auch die Richtlinie, finde ich, dich erklärt, sodass man also nicht mehr argumentieren kann, wir müssen dringend eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung schaffen, weil ja das Europarecht uns das vorgibt. Das heißt also, es gibt keine Pflicht mehr zur Speicherung über die Telekom. Wie du gesagt hast, die Telekom will ja debuggen. Und in der Tat gibt es dazu auch eine Vorschrift, die ihr das Speichern von IPs zum Debugging erlaubt. So jedenfalls hat es der Bundesgerichtshof jetzt entschieden. Also der Streit ging letztlich darum, ob eine siebentägige Speicherung von IP-Adressen im Kundenkonto des Nutzers, also eine siebentägige Speicherung der Zuordnung Nutzer IP-Adresse, ob die unter der Überschrift Debugging in Ordnung ist. Und da hat der BGH gesagt, das ist in der Tat der Fall. Und wenn man sich diese Entscheidung mal genauer anschaut, dann war die wesentliche Begründung da der Spam-Schutz. Also die Telekom hat argumentiert, wenn von einer IP, von einer dynamischen IP Spam versendet wird, dann führt das dazu, dass die Systeme der Telekom, wenn da also dieser Spam eingeliefert wird und das über deren Mail-Server weiterverbreitet wird, diese Systeme der Telekom möglicherweise von anderen Mail-Servern auf die Blacklist gesetzt werden. Das heißt also, wenn eine dynamische IP aus dem Netz der Telekom über Telekom-Server Spam versendet, dann könnte es sein, dass die Telekom-Server insgesamt nicht mehr so richtig funktionieren. Und das ist eine Argumentation, die der BGH quasi gekauft hat. Und deswegen darf die Telekom jetzt sieben Tage lang diese Zuordnung speichern unter der Überschrift Debugging. Und zwar zunächst mal nicht unter der Überschrift Strafverfolgung oder Gefahrenabwehr.
Aber dieses Argument ist technisch aber nicht wirklich sinnvoll, oder? Also ich meine, am Ende würde diese dynamische IP-Adresse ja über eine oder mehrere Email-Adressen Spam versenden. Und die Telekom könnte daran natürlich ihr Debugging-Problem in den Griff kriegen. Also der Versand von Spam-Mails wird ja nicht auf der IP-Adressebene gelöst, sondern der wird ja auf dem Mailserver gelöst. Und die Telekom-Mailserver können natürlich sehr schnell erkennen, wenn da ein Nutzer auf einmal durchdreht und ein paar hundert Mails verschickt.
Genau.
Und das könnten sie einmal auf einer IP-Adressebene, ohne die IP-Adresse länger zu speichern. Wenn einer IP sich auf einmal andauernd anmeldet mit unterschiedlichen Identitäten. Oder eben auf Ebene der Absender-Mail-Adresse, wo sie eben sehen, diese Mail-Adresse versendet auf einmal eine hohe Anzahl Mails pro Tag. Was auch nicht geht, weil die nämlich alle so ein Rate-Limit haben. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwie in die Nähe der 500 Empfänger kommst, dann kriegst du das nicht mehr rausgeschoben aus deinem normalen Mailserver.
Ja, ich kenne natürlich die Details jetzt auch nicht, die da in dem Verfahren diskutiert wurden. Also insofern die technischen Details. Man muss da die Gerichte so ein Klitzeklannesbissieren in Schutz nehmen, denn der BGH berichtet quasi von der Entscheidung des Oberlandesgerichts, die er wiederum in der Revision zu prüfen hatte, dass es da einen Sachverständigen gegeben hat, der dem Oberlandesgericht seine Sachkunden zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Und dieser Sachkunde hat wohl gesagt, so steht es hier in dem Urteil des Oberlandesgerichts, nach den überzeugenden Angaben des vom Gericht beauftragten Sachverständigen gäbe es nach dem derzeitigen Stand der Technik keine anderen Möglichkeiten als die von der Beklagten, also der Telekom, praktizierte Speicherung, um Störungen der Telekommunikationsanlagen zu erkennen, einzugrenzen und notfalls zu beseitigen. Mit anderen Worten, die Telekom hat einen Sachverständigen gefunden, der ihr letztlich bescheinigt hat, es geht nur so. Da muss man der Fairness halber sagen, was soll das Gericht dann tun? Natürlich können die Richter im Oberlandesgericht sicherlich noch viel weniger als wir hier einschätzen, ob die Argumentation technisch stichhaltig ist.
Okay, sieben Tage. Und es kam natürlich die Frage auf, du hast sie am Rande schon beantwortet, unterläuft dieses Urteil jetzt die EU-Gesetzgebung?
Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Weil ja der EuGH die Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung in ihrer Ausführung kritisiert hat.
Genau, ich glaube, da muss man so ein kleines bisschen vorsichtig sein, denn der EuGH hat ja nicht direkt gesagt, dass überhaupt keine IP-Adressenspeicherung mit dem Europarecht vereinbart ist. Der EuGH hat im Prinzip gesagt, was jedenfalls nicht geht, ist eine sechsmonatige Zwangsspeicherung, wenn das nicht eng begrenzt ist auf ganz eng begrenzte Deliktsbereiche. Was der EuGH eigentlich gesagt hat, ist, es fehlt ihm an einer Verhältnismäßigkeit. Die Richtlinie war quasi zu breit. Der EuGH hat das wiederum auch ein bisschen unklar formuliert in einigen Stellen. Deswegen hat sich quasi die Interpretation dieser Entscheidung durchgesetzt. Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht gar nicht. Und das finde ich auch sehr gut, dass das jetzt so ist auf europäischer Ebene. Es würde aber, glaube ich, diese Entscheidung etwas überstrapazieren. Wenn man da jetzt rauslesen würde, IP-Adressen dürfen überhaupt gar nicht mehr gespeichert werden. Das sagt das Europarecht, denke ich, nicht. Und eine weitere Frage ist, inwieweit das Europarecht eigentlich unmittelbar durchschlagen würde auf diese deutsche Regelung. Denn, wie gesagt, die Telekom beruft sich ja auf einen deutschen Paragrafen, den Paragrafen 100 Absatz 1 im Telekommunikationsgesetz. Und jetzt zu sagen, der ist also unmittelbar europarechtswidrig, ganz so einfach kann man sich das, glaube ich, nicht machen.
Was besagt denn der 100 Absatz 1 Telekommunikationsgesetz?
Genau, das ist eben die Norm, die Datenspeicherung aus diesen technischen Gründen zulässt, die auch die Telekom angeführt hat. Da heißt es nämlich so schön, das ist sogar mal ganz lesbar. Soweit erforderlich darf der Dienst der Anbieter zum Erkennen, Eingrenzen oder Beseitigen von Störungen oder Fehlern an Telekommunikationsanlagen die Bestandsdaten und Verkehrsdaten der Teilnehmer und Nutzer erheben und verwenden. Also eine Regelung, die zu diesem eingegrenzten technischen Zweck erlaubt, Bestandsdaten und Verkehrsdaten zu erheben und zu verwenden. Bestandsdaten sind quasi die Kundendaten, Name, Anschrift und Verkehrsdaten, wer ist wann, mit welcher IP unterwegs.
So, aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass da die Polizei dann auch zugreifen darf.
Genau, und das ist nämlich der Punkt, wo diese Entscheidung eigentlich spannend wird. Man muss dazu wissen, das ist eine Entscheidung von einem Zivilsenat. Das war ja ein Streit zwischen einem zivilen Menschen und der zivilen Telekom. Da geht es also eigentlich überhaupt nicht um Strafrecht. Aber der BGH-Zivilsenat hat da in einem Nebensatz auf ein Detail hingewiesen, das bislang eigentlich keiner so richtig auf der Rechnung hatte, muss man sagen. Da hatte nämlich also der Kläger, der Bürger, der diese Speicherung eigentlich nicht wollte, der hatte argumentiert, es gibt doch jetzt keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mehr, deswegen dürfen die Daten auch nicht mehr zur Strafverfolgung gespeichert werden. Da hat der BGH erstmal gesagt, ne, wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe, geht ja auch gar nicht um Strafverfolgung. Und dann sagt der BGH aber, die Speicherung erfolgt nicht, also bei diesen 101-Fällen, erfolgt nicht für die Zwecke der Strafverfolgungsbehörden, sondern im Interesse des Netzbetreibers. Ein Zugriff von Polizei oder Staatsanwaltschaft auf die gespeicherten Daten ist in dieser Rechtsgrundlage nicht vorgesehen. Und das ist in der Tat sehr interessant, denn bislang hat niemand so richtig darauf geschaut, auf welcher Grundlage eigentlich Daten gespeichert waren. Das heißt also, wenn die Polizei zum Beispiel oder die Staatsanwaltschaft eine Anfrage an einen Provider richtet, sag uns doch mal, wer hatte zu der und der Zeit die IP so und so, dann haben die Provider einfach geguckt, haben wir die Daten noch, haben aber nicht danach geguckt, auf welcher Grundlage sie diese Daten eigentlich haben. Und was der BGH hier im Nebensatz gesagt hat, ist, wenn ihr die Daten nur noch habt auf Grundlage von 100 Absatz 1 und nicht mehr z.B. zu Abrechnungszwecken, dann dürft ihr diese Daten auch gar nicht verwenden. Und das ist eine ganz interessante Konsequenz, denn die hat bislang noch niemand gezogen. Also selbst irgendwie quasi Bürgerrechtler haben bislang noch nicht argumentiert, dass man diese Differenzierung eigentlich einführen muss. Aber der BGH ist da sehr deutlich an dieser Stelle. Das heißt also, wenn man das mal ernst nimmt, dann ist diese Entscheidung eigentlich aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht denke ich sehr positiv, weil man zwar diese IPs speichern kann, aber da muss man sagen, es steht halt auch so im Gesetz. Was soll man tun? Auf der anderen Seite dürfen diese Daten aber eben nicht an Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder Geheimdienste herausgegeben werden.
Das heißt, jetzt müsste es ein Verfahren geben, wo jemand sagt, die haben Daten, die nach Paragraph 100, Absatz 1 Telekommunikationsgesetz gespeichert wurden, zweckentfremdet und der Polizei gegeben. Das dürfen die aber gar nicht.
Genau, das wäre jetzt in der Tat die Konsequenz. Da muss jetzt noch mal juristisch nachgesetzt werden. Denn diese Differenzierung hat bislang keiner getroffen. Du hast das ja eigentlich voraussetzt aus der IT-Perspektive. Das ist eine Art Tagging. Man müsste jetzt im Grunde jeden IP-Datensatz mit der Rechtsgrundlage taggen. Also quasi dazu notieren, warum haben wir dieses Datum noch?
Gibt es denn andere Gründe, diese Daten aufzubewahren?
Typischerweise speichert man diese Daten ja zu Abrechnungszwecken. Natürlich nicht in den Flatrate-Fällen.
Das heißt, es könnte theoretisch, wir wissen ja, dass so schöne Konstruktionen leider verhindert werden. Aber es könnte sein, dass man mit einer Flatrate dann quasi Schutz genießen könnte vor einer Abmahnung, weil die Netzbetreiber diese Daten nicht rausgeben dürfen, während ein anderer Nutzer, der keine Flatrate hat, der wäre in Gefahr. Aber wer keine Flatrate hat, betreibt ja auch kein exzessives File-Sharing. Also wäre das Problem der Abmahnung... Naja, ich halte das jetzt nicht für realistisch, dass es so eine Entscheidung auch gibt, oder? Also ich meine, du kennst das Fach besser als ich.
Ja gut, ich meine, Abmahnungen sind auch noch mal ein anderer Fall. Denn Abmahnungen werden ja inzwischen nicht mehr verfolgt über den Umweg Strafverfolgung. Das war ein paar Jahre mal in. Ein paar Jahre haben Rechteinhaber quasi Massenanzeigen erstattet. Dann haben die Staatsanwaltschaften die IPs abgefragt. Wer hatte diese IP? Und dann haben die Rechteinhaber ein paar Wochen später Akteneinsicht genommen. In diese Ermittlungsakten haben dann geguckt, wer hatte die IP und haben dann im zweiten Schritt abgemahnt. Und dann aber haben die Strafverfolgungsbehörden irgendwann geschrien und haben gesagt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, wir kriegen hier jeden Monat 20.000 Anzeigen und machen im Prinzip nur diese IP-Auskünfte. Und daraufhin hat dann der Gesetzgeber reagiert und hat den Rechteinhabern ein eigenes Recht gegeben, diese IPs abfragen zu lassen. Das sind genau die Fälle, die jetzt zum Beispiel...
Sofern sie die mit einem irgendwie verbrieft Verfahren ermittelt haben. Das war ja glaube ich dann bei dieser RedTube-Abmahnung noch die Bedingung.
Genau, das sind diese RedTube-Fälle. Jetzt gibt es quasi ein eigenes Recht, wo der Rechteinhaber direkt zum Gericht gehen kann und sagen kann, sag mir mal bitte zu der IP so und so, wer die hatte. Und dann gibt es, wenn die Voraussetzungen vorliegen, gibt es einen Beschluss. Und dann muss der Provider an den Rechteinhaber rausgeben, wer diese IP hatte zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Das hat also zunächst mal mit der Frage, wie ist es mit Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder wie ist es mit der Polizei zunächst mal nichts zu tun. Aber in all diesen Fällen, also egal ob Urheberrechtsgesetz oder Zugriff von Strafverfolgungsbehörden, stellt sich halt immer die Frage, dürfen da die 101 Daten überhaupt verwendet werden? Bislang, wie gesagt, wurden alle Daten in einen Topf geschmissen. Was da war, wurde beauskundet nach den Abfragenormen, ob nun Urheberrechtsgesetz oder 112, 113 TKG. Das sind also die Abfragenormen für die Polizei. Aber wie gesagt, nach dieser Entscheidung dürfte das so ohne Weiteres nicht mehr funktionieren. Und man muss ja schon sagen, aus datenschutzrechtlicher Perspektive steht ausdrücklich drin in dem 101, was der Zweck der Speicherung ist. Der Zweck der Speicherung ist nämlich Störungsbeseitigung. Und wenn man dann diese Daten verwendet zur Beauskundung von Urheberrechtsansprüchen oder von Auskunftsersuchen der Polizei, dann ist das ja ein Zweckwechsel. Das ist ein datenschutzrechtlicher Zweckwechsel dieser gespeicherten Daten. Und dafür braucht es eine eigene Ermächtigungsgrundlage. Und wenn man mal das Zielkommunikationsgesetz genau anguckt, ich sehe keine Ermächtigungsgrundlage. Und auch die Abfragenormen verweisen nicht auf den 100. Wenn es um die Frage geht, welche Daten verwendet werden können. Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt neu, muss man sagen. Auf den Gedanken ist bislang noch niemand so richtig gekommen. War ja auch nicht so richtig aktuell, bis die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekippt wurde. Aber jetzt wird es also wirklich spannend, ob diese Daten eigentlich verwendet werden können. Und insofern, das ist, glaube ich, ein kreatives Betätigungsfeld. Da müssten jetzt mal ein paar Aufsätze geschrieben werden. Und es müssten mal Strafverteidiger da quasi reingerätschen. Nachdem ja der BGH im Grunde eine steile Vorlage geliefert hat.
Vielen Dank für diese fachmännische Einschätzung. Wir schreiten, glaube ich, mal weiter zu einem eher ein bisschen boulevardesten Thema. Also wir haben jetzt so schöne, die schönen juristischen Sachen, die wollten wir ja, dafür wollte ich dich ja auch da haben. Aber wir müssen natürlich auch sagen, es gibt ja auch noch ein Leben außerhalb der Juristerei. Denn es gibt auch einfach mal das schöne Poltern. Glenn Greenwald hat seinen Auftritt im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss abgesagt. Er sollte dort am 11. September zu den Feierlichkeiten angehört werden als Sachverständiger und hat gesagt, dadurch dass die deutschen Politiker es abgelehnt haben, den einen Schlüsselzeugen, nämlich Edward Snowden, zu vernehmen, hätten sie jetzt wirklich unter Beweis gestellt, dass es ihnen wichtiger sei, die USA nicht gegen sich aufzubringen, statt über die NSA-Spionage ernsthaft aufklären und diskutieren zu wollen. Und deswegen ist er nicht bereit, an einem Ritual mitzuwirken, das den Anschein einer Untersuchung erwecken soll. Großartig, oder?
Harte Worte. Der sagt halt sehr deutlich, Leute, wenn ihr ganz bewusst den besten Zeugen nicht wollt, dann spiele ich hier auch nicht stand in. Ganz genau, dann spiele ich hier auch nicht irgendwie den Vertreter. Ja, finde ich ehrlich gesagt eine sehr souveräne Position, wobei man natürlich schon sagen muss, es ist zugleich auch bedauerlich, denn natürlich wird der Ausschuss dadurch noch etwas schlechter ermitteln können. Das muss man sagen. Auch wenn der Glenn Greenwald natürlich nur quasi Zeuge vom Hörensagen ist und nicht unmittelbar dabei war, so ist er doch, denke ich, eine der Personen, die den Fundus an NSA-Unterlagen, die Snowden gesammelt und geleakt hat, am besten kennt. Denn er hat das ja durchgearbeitet. Wahrscheinlich so gut wie kaum ein anderer Journalist oder überhaupt kann man ein anderer Mensch. Insofern denke ich, ist es für den Untersuchungsausschuss ausgesprochen bitter. Auf der anderen Seite muss man dann wieder sehen, es ist ja auch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen. Wenn man das jetzt mal als taktisches Manöver versteht, dass Greenwald sagt, ich erhöhe jetzt mal so ein bisschen den Druck und ich spiele auch so ein bisschen auf Zeit, dann kann das ja vielleicht Sinn machen. Vielleicht da ein Wort zum Hintergrund, also dass Edward Snowden tatsächlich nicht vernommen werden kann, ist ja auch durchaus noch nicht das letzte Wort. Denn Grüne und Linke haben ja schon angekündigt, dass sie, wenn der Ausschuss dabei bleiben sollte, Snowden nicht mal zu laden oder nicht mal einzuladen, dann wollen sie das Bundesverfassungsgericht dagegen anrufen. Weil es eben eine quasi systematische Blockade der Ausschussarbeit wäre. Und in der Tat, denke ich, hat das Argument einiges für sich, dass es nicht angehen kann, den besten Belastungszeugen schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht erst zu hören. Ob das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann soweit geht, quasi im Detail reinzugrätschen in die Ausschussarbeit, das vermag ich überhaupt nicht vorherzusehen. Aber man muss schon sehen, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich eigentlich sehr viel Mühe gegeben hat, die Oppositionsrechte zu stärken und die Arbeit der Untersuchungsausschüsse zu stärken. Ich denke, das ist eine völlig offene Frage. Ich habe keine internen Kenntnisse, aber könnte mir vorstellen, dass Greenwald einfach sagt, naja, warten wir es doch mal ab. Vielleicht schaffen die es ja tatsächlich, noch etwas Snowden ranzuholen. Wenn ich so lange nicht komme, dann bleibt der Druck wenigstens auf dem Kessel, dass Aufklärung weiter nötig ist. Insofern könnte man sagen, wenn er gekommen wäre, hätte er im Zweifel die Klage von Grünen und Linken so ein Stück weit torpediert, ohne es zu wollen. Weil dann einfach die Aufklärungsarbeit möglicherweise schon so weit fortgeschritten wäre, dass man sagen könnte, na nun braucht man Snowden nicht mehr. Und das wäre natürlich sehr bedauerlich gewesen.
Das stimmt. Und das wäre natürlich auch tatsächlich eine Argumentation, die man diesem Ausschuss durchaus zutrauen kann. Also ich habe dieser Ausschuss, ich meine, klar Snowden da nicht einzuladen, das war einerseits natürlich zu erwarten, dass sie das nicht tun würden oder dass sie es versuchen würden, zu vermeiden, weil sich Deutschland durchaus in eine sehr unangenehme Situation damit bebringen würde in dem Verhältnis zu den USA. Andererseits genieße ich das natürlich auch auf eine gewisse Form, wenn die schon so einen schmieren Theater davor führen. Dass es dann auch wenigstens wirklich von allen Seiten rasselt. Und es gibt eben nur wenige Personen, die ernsthaft diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss kritisieren können. Und zwar ohne, dass die Herkunft dieser Kritik im Auge des Betrachters liegt. Wenn der CCC sich hinstellt und sagt, dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss ist ja wohl ein Witz, was er ja nicht tut, Frank war ja da. Aber wenn also jetzt mal von digitaler Gesellschaft, von CCC, von netzpolitik.org oder so da Kritik dran geübt wird, dann ist das irgendwie klar, das kommt aus der Ecke, von der eh immer nur gemosert wird. Und die auch natürlich nicht so gehört hat wie Glenn Greenwald. Aber wenn dieser Mann, dieses gesamte Gremium, da infrage stellt, und zwar genau auf seine wirkliche Existenzgrundlage hin kritisiert, also in einer Linie mit dem Ziel, dass sich das eigene Gremium auf die Fahne geschrieben hat, dann ist das natürlich schon eine Wahnsinnssache. Also das ist schon nicht umsonst natürlich ein Riesending.
Ja, das muss man in der Tat sagen. Und um jetzt noch mal so ein kleines bisschen die Brücke zu schlagen zu meinem Job, also einer der wichtigsten Zeugen in jedem Strafverfahren, jedenfalls in jedem Strafverfahren wegen Mordes, ist quasi der Ermittlungsführer. Also wir haben ja in Berlin eine Reihe von Mordkommissionen, die sitzen da in der Kaitstraße. Und die machen, soweit ich das einschätzen kann, einen ganz großartigen Job. Und da gibt es halt immer einen Beamten, der den Hut auf hat. Und das ist typischerweise einer der ersten Zeugen, den wir hören, weil der uns einen Überblick über die Ermittlungen gibt und der erklärt uns, was haben wir in welcher Reihenfolge gemacht, wie haben wir eigentlich welche Beweismittel erhoben, wie sind wir auf den Angeklagten gekommen. Und im Grunde verhält es sich ja bei diesem Untersuchungsausschuss ganz genauso. Ja, was die jetzt im Prinzip machen, ist, irgendwelche peripheren Zeugen zu vernehmen, aber eben gerade nicht den zentralen Zeugen, der das gesamte Beweismaterial gesammelt hat und der sich dabei ja was gedacht hat. Also wenn man mal das Buch vom Greenworld gelesen hat, das ist ja nicht einfach nur ein unstrukturierter Haufen PDFs, sondern der Snowden hat sich dabei ja was gedacht. Der hat ja bestimmte Dinge runtergeladen. Der hat die in eine Ordnerstruktur gebracht. Also quasi diese Dateisammlung ist im Grunde aufbereitet. Und das heißt also, da steht jemand dahinter, der die gesamte Arbeit dieser Behörde kennt, aus eigener Innenansicht, der jahrelang dafür gearbeitet hat und der dann jahrelang quasi belastende Dokumente zusammengestellt hat, um die Arbeit dieser Behörde quasi mal in zur öffentlichen Debatte zu stellen. Und wer so genau dieser Mann der ideale Hauptbelastungszeuge wäre, der Ermittlungsführer quasi gegen die NSA, dass genau dieser Mann nicht gehört werden soll, das ist, wenn man mal diesen Untersuchungszweck ins Zentrum rückt, vollkommen unverständlich. Ich denke, verständlich wird das nur vor dem Hintergrund, dass es natürlich, wenn er einmal in Deutschland wäre, ganz, ganz schwierig wäre, dem Mann keinen Asyl zu gewähren. Das wäre vermutlich nicht ganz einfach zu begründen. Und auf der anderen Seite wäre es auch diplomatisch ganz, ganz heikel, ihm Asyl zu gewähren. Mit anderen Worten, Deutschland käme zugegebenermaßen in eine heikle Lage. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Regierungsfraktionen einfach sagen, also, für diese Entscheidung möchten wir einfach gar nicht gestellt werden.
Hinzu kommt, das finde ich immer ganz wichtig, da nochmal zu betonen, dass natürlich, wenn Edward Snowden aussagt, dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, wie er jetzt schon auch genannt wird, hat ja auch in seinem Titel, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie der ganze Titel ist, der Titel ist ja relativ lang, die Aufgabe, nicht nur die NSA zu untersuchen, sondern natürlich auch die Zusammenarbeit mit den deutschen Geheimdiensten. Und ich glaube, dass die Bundesregierung sich im Moment eigentlich noch mit dieser öffentlichen Wahrnehmung ganz zufrieden zeigen kann, dass nämlich das Ganze immer noch der NSA-Skandal ist, die die größte Meldung ist und bleibt, die alle Menschen sich gemerkt haben, das kann es darin, Handy wird abgehört. Die Zusammenarbeit mit den deutschen Diensten, die Massenüberwachung der deutschen Bürger durch, natürlich auch die deutschen Dienste, die da mitarbeiten, sind nicht so in den Vordergrund gerückt und ich glaube, dass die Bundesregierung natürlich, ich meine, die Situation ist jetzt nicht angenehm, zu sagen, okay, die Amerikaner spionieren uns aus und wir wären uns nicht wirklich dagegen. Aber es hätte eben auch so sein können, dass mal wirklich laut diskutiert wird, was ja eigentlich sich dahinter verbirgt. Es gibt hier eine Massenüberwachung, es gibt eine Zusammenarbeit der Geheimdienste. Wir stecken da knietief mit drin. Und insofern, glaube ich, ist die Situation der deutschen Bundesregierung im Moment noch nicht mal die unangenehmste gemessen. An dem, wie sie auch sein könnte zum gleichen Zeitpunkt jetzt.
Also insbesondere gibt es ja quasi diese Kickback-Zahlung, dass also Daten aus Deutschland über die NSA erhoben werden und dann an den BND zurückfließen. Und ich glaube, dass das aus der deutschen Perspektive fast der größere Skandal sein könnte. Also ich meine, wenn amerikanische Behörden was über deutsche Bürger wissen, ist das nicht schön. Das bleibt ein schwerer Grundrechtseingriff. Aber im Zweifel, wenn ich jetzt nicht in die USA reise, passiert mir dann auch nichts. Also ganz ehrlich, die Konsequenzen, wenn irgendeine amerikanische Behörde was über mich weiß, sind zunächst mal vergleichsweise überschaubar. Ganz anders sieht das aber natürlich aus, wenn eine deutsche Behörde über mich im Zweifel meine gesamten E-Mails kennt, wenn man mich genau Bescheid weiß. Und diese Behörde dann, wie der BND, über die Zusammenarbeit der Dienste möglicherweise wiederum auch Informationen an andere Behörden weitergeben kann. Also zum Beispiel an die Polizei. Wir haben ja theoretischen Trennungsgebot. Das ist aber inzwischen weitgehend ausgehöhlt, weil es eben bestimmte Strukturen der Zusammenarbeit gibt. Das heißt also, Geheimdienste können auch doch Informationen zurückfüttern an die Polizei. Und ich glaube, da wird es erst so richtig schlimm. Also die NSA überwacht uns zwar in Deutschland, aber es gibt sehr deutliche Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass viele dieser Informationen an deutsche Stellen zurückfließen. Und dann irgendwann ist es fast wurscht, ob der BND im Inland spioniert, was er nicht darf, oder ob der Formal sagt, nö, das machen wir ja gar nicht, das machen ja die Amerikaner, und dann aber auf irgendwelchen Geheimleitungen die Daten aber doch wieder zurückfließen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was der Flurschaden, den die deutsche Bundesregierung jetzt irgendwie sich noch sparen möchte.
Also das muss man sagen, da haben sie einfach bislang Glück gehabt, dass die öffentliche Diskussion, genau wie du es gesagt hast, um das Kanzlerin-Handykreis und darum, die quasi auf die bösen Amerikaner zu zeigen. Aber ich glaube, das ist einfach in gewisser Hinsicht auch unfair. Also da wird natürlich von amerikanischer Seite jetzt auch nicht entgegengetreten. Aber das ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch unfair, weil die vielleicht größere Gefahr für die Freiheitsausübung in unserem Lande darin besteht, dass eben deutsche Dienste viele, viele Dinge wissen, die sie auf legale Weise niemals erfahren könnten. Und die natürlich auch viel größere Konsequenzen haben können, potenziell. Also je nachdem, was man eben so tut.
Eine weitere Meldung der letzten Woche. Eigentlich nur etwas, was dann auch wieder so in diesem schönen überlegen Bereich ist. Es gab dieses Leak der Kriterien, wie du auf der Terrorliste der USA landen kannst. Und wie viele Menschen da drauf sind. Das Leak als solches war, fand ich jetzt gar nicht so überraschend. Da waren dann eineinhalb Millionen Menschen da drauf. Es gibt keinen wirklich geordneten Prozess, wie du da drauf kommst. Und die Konsequenz auf dieser Terrorliste zu stehen, ist natürlich dann, dass du beim Screening im USA-Aufflug teilweise schon am Abflugort gehindert wirst, teilweise dir die Einreise an Ort und Stelle verwehrt wird. Das ist eine Sorge, die natürlich viele politische Aktivisten, Journalisten und natürlich auch Hacker haben. Ich habe da natürlich auch mal kurz mitgesponnen, als ich letztes Jahr in die USA geflogen bin. Und werde es auch dieses Jahr dann wieder kurz meinen kleinen Schweißausbruch kriegen. Bei einer Million Menschen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich da draufstehe, aber immer noch relativ gering. Also man sieht da einfach, dieses System ist aus der außer Rand und Band. Das funktioniert ja offensichtlich auch nicht. Wenn du eineinhalb Millionen Menschen auf so einer Liste hast, dann heißt das, du hast deine Liste nicht unter Kontrolle. Also du hast offensichtlich auch keinen vernünftigen Umgang damit. Du weißt gar nicht, was du da machen musst. Oder wirst da deine Aufgabe auch nicht gerecht. Das sind dann deren Probleme. Im Prinzip, schlimmer hätte ich es gefunden, wenn da so etwas wie 1500 drauf gestanden hätte, weil dann wüssten sie, wie man ihre Arbeit ernsthaft betreibt. Das ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall. Insofern fand ich dieses Leak gar nicht so besonders spannend oder interessant. Natürlich ist dieser Prozess vollständig intransparent. Du hast keine Möglichkeit, dich dagegen zu wehren. Wenn wir als Europäer die USA sagen, wir möchten dich hier nicht einreisen lassen, hast du gar keine Möglichkeit, dich da juristisch auf irgendeinem definierten Prozess gegenzuwehren. Das heißt, da gibt es keine rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien. Aber ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig sehe, muss ein Land die auch nicht haben, weil das Land ja die Hoheit über seinen eigenen Grund und Boden hat und da entscheiden kann, wer da reinkommt oder nicht. Das sind sie ja nicht gegenüber Bürgern, die nicht Bürger dieses Landes sind, zu einem Due Process verpflichtet, oder sehe ich das falsch?
Im Prinzip dürfte das so sein. Da muss ich gestehen, bin ich jetzt auch kein Fachmann. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass jedes Land mehr oder weniger selber entscheiden kann, wen es reinlässt. Und in den USA ist es zum Beispiel so, dass die abschließende und endgültige Entscheidung tatsächlich immer der Kontrollbeamte an der Grenze trifft. Und da gibt es in der Tat auch überhaupt kein Rechtsmittel. Das heißt, der kann völlig frei entscheiden, Daumen hoch oder Daumen runter. Selbst wenn man ein Visum hat. Also zum Beispiel, als ich in den USA studiert habe, hatte ich natürlich ein Visum, sonst hätte ich da nicht studieren dürfen. Aber trotzdem war das überhaupt keine Garantie, dass ich auch reingekommen bin. Also ich bin reingekommen und ich bin ja während des Jahres auch nicht ausgereist. Doch, das stimmt, ich war immer in Kanada. Aber ich bin quasi zweimal reingekommen. Und zwar haben die Kontrollbeamten da kein Problem mit gehabt. Aber das ist in der Tat jedes Mal wieder so ein kleiner Stressfaktor. Also gerade eben, wenn man irgendwie, sagen wir mal, sich irgendwie in bürgerrechtlicher Szene bewegt.
Wobei meine, also ehrlich gesagt, meine Sorge zu keinem Zeitpunkt ist, dass die mich nicht in dieses Land lassen. Meine Sorge ist natürlich eher, dass die mein Handy oder meinen Computer sehen wollen.
Das ist eine unschöne Situation.
Können wir da mal kurz drüberwischen. Jetzt haben sie auch noch diese neue Regel, man darf mit einem Leer, also man sollte sein Telefon geladen ins Land bringen.
Besser ist es ja.
An dieser Kontrolle. Aber diese gesamte Flugsicherheit und Einreisekontrolle in den USA war schon immer völlig dystopisch. Insofern nichts Neues bei diesem Leak. Das Spannende aber ist, dass sich dieses Leak auf ein Datum zurückführen lässt, von wann nämlich diese Liste und diese Kriterien stammen. Und dieses Datum liegt quasi nach Edward Snowdens Flucht oder Edward Snowdens Entdeckung. Also Edward Snowdens Werbung des Snowdens.
Das hatte ich gar nicht hinbekommen bisher.
Und das befeuert jetzt Spekulationen darüber, dass es einen weiteren Whistleblower geben könnte.
Oh, das ist in der Tat interessant, denn die Liste muss ja irgendwie aus den Systemen rausgerutscht sein.
Die muss irgendwoher kommen. Und das wäre natürlich jetzt nochmal eine echt coole Sache, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich noch einen zweiten Whistleblower in diesem Bereich gibt. Wenn Snowden dann tatsächlich nicht so einen Assange-sozialen Heldentod sterben würde, ohne dass er jemals Nachahmer findet, sondern als das, was Julian Assange immer sein wollte, ein Mensch, der Mut macht, auch wirklich dann wirkt. Das war bei Julian Assange nicht der Fall, aufgrund verschiedener Persönlichkeitseigenschaften, dass er für andere eine Inspiration dann am Ende geworden wäre. Aber das wäre natürlich jetzt sehr schön, wenn Edward Snowden jetzt tatsächlich die Inspiration wird, für andere Menschen eben auch diesen Mut zu erfassen.
Ja, das wäre es in der Tat. Das finde ich zum Beispiel auch sehr interessant. Es gibt in den USA da gerade eine sehr engagierte Diskussion, wie man gerade, also schon seit den ersten Leaks vor einem Jahr, wie denn eigentlich seine Rolle einzuschätzen ist. Ob er eigentlich ein Verräter oder ein Patriot ist. Und da zeigt sich die klassische Bruchlinie in der amerikanischen politischen Landschaft. Zwischen den quasi liberalen, verfassungstreuen quasi, die eher der Meinung sind, naja, da hat jemand eben aufgedeckt, dass eine Behörde außer Rat und Band geraten ist. Und anderen, die sagen, naja, aber da hat er doch quasi Amerikas Feinden geholfen, auch wenn unsere vielleicht nicht mit fairen Mitteln gespielt haben. Ja, ich finde das auch sehr erfreulich. Denn wenn es jetzt Nachahmer gäbe auf der anderen Seite, muss man natürlich immer sehen, dass der persönliche Preis schon sehr hoch ist. Also jetzt hat er ja ein neues 3-Jahres-Visum bekommen. Das heißt, er kann jetzt noch 3 Jahre in Russland bleiben. Das Visum ist, glaube ich, auch mit weniger Restriktionen ausgestattet. Er kann sich jetzt im Land frei bewegen. Aber das ist natürlich schon etwas anderes, in Russland zu leben als in seiner Heimat. Also ich denke mal, jedenfalls, als er eingereist ist, damals hat er vermutlich kaum ein Wort Russisch gekonnt. Natürlich hat er seine Freundin und seine Familie zurückgelassen. Da muss man schon ein sehr starkes Gewissen haben, denke ich, um diesen Preis persönlich zu zahlen.
Russland ist ja jetzt auch nicht das Land der Wahl. Da wäre ich ja lieber in Ecuador.
Ich denke, man isst besser und es ist auch wärmer.
Ja, aber es wäre natürlich schön. Wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, wenn die Allmacht der Geheimdienste jetzt wirklich schon auf dieser Ebene ist, dass sie ihre parlamentarischen Kontrollgremien angreifen, und zwar mit bösartigen Interventionen, dann muss man sich natürlich wirklich überlegen, welche Möglichkeiten haben wir überhaupt noch aus dieser Spirale rauszukommen, wenn demokratische Bemühungen ein großes Risiko haben, nicht nur unterwandert, sondern auch aktiv sabotiert zu werden. Und dann bleibt ja vielleicht auch nur noch wirklich als einzige Hoffnung, dieses System wenn nicht zu zersetzen, dann zumindest irgendwie auch aufzuhalten oder nochmal in Schranken zu weisen, genau diese Whistleblower, die von innen das zersetzen. Das muss ja nicht jeder jemand sein, der wie Edward Snowden mit einer Menge Daten da rausgeht und eine Flucht ins Exil ergreifen muss und sein Leben opfert, wie es war. Sondern es können ja auch Täter sein, die dann mal ein Dokument aus Versehen irgendwo fallen lassen, ja, unvorsichtig damit agieren und nicht diese Massen-Leaks machen. Vielleicht auch so eine Taktik des steten Tropfens, die vielleicht dieses System nochmal bremsen könnte.
Ich denke, ganz, ganz wichtig ist, dass sich nach Snowden eigentlich kein Verantwortlicher in einem solchen Dienst mehr sicher sein kann, dass Schweinereien nicht auffliegen. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht persönlich auch der zentrale demokratische Gewinn eines Whistleblowers. Es geht natürlich zum einen immer um den Effekt im Einzelfall, dass bestimmte Dinge enthüllt und diskutiert werden. Aber was eigentlich viel wichtiger ist, aus meiner Sicht, ist quasi die Breitenwirkung. Dass die Verantwortlichen in Geheimdiensten zum Beispiel, die bislang immer denken konnten, wir machen hier, was wir wollen, und denen im Parlament erzählen wir, was wir wollen, und die kommen uns eh nicht auf die Schliche. Dass die jetzt einfach damit rechnen müssen nach dem Snowden-Beispiel, dass ihnen das alles um die Ohren fliegt. Und ich weiß natürlich nicht, ob das jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass in der NSA ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht wird, sich möglicherweise in Zukunft mal an Recht und Gesetz zu halten. Das kann ich nicht sagen. Das Beispiel, was die CIA jetzt hier abgeliefert hat, spricht eigentlich eher dafür, dass die genauso dreist sind wie eh und je. Das muss man natürlich schon sagen. Insofern ist mein Optimismus vielleicht auch ein bisschen überspitzt. Aber ich denke trotzdem, dass das immerhin ein kleines bisschen dazu führen kann, dass sich Dienste kontrolliert fühlen. Denn die parlamentarische Kontrolle ist sicherlich nicht besonders wirksam. Also zum einen, also dieser CIA-Fall ist natürlich ein absoluter Extremfall. Ich würde jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass zum Beispiel die parlamentarischen Kontrollgremien des Bundestages ständig abgehört werden. Also das will ich nicht ausschließen. Ich weiß es nicht, aber so weit muss man gar nicht gehen. Ich glaube, die Kontrolle ist aus viel banaleren Gründen ineffizient. Nämlich einfach deswegen, weil sicher nur kontrolliert werden kann, was die Dienste freiwillig vorlegen. Das heißt, die Dienste stellen sich selber ein Zeugnis aus und der parlamentarische Kontrollgremien darf dann sagen, stimmt, war okay. Und ich meine, dass das mit Kontrolle nichts zu tun hat, das ist völlig klar. Also das muss man einfach so deutlich sagen. Ich will gar nicht jetzt quasi hier die steile These aufstellen, wir müssen alle Geheimdienste morgen zumachen. Dazu kenne ich deren Arbeit vielleicht dann doch zu wenig. Was ich aber auf jeden Fall sagen kann, ist, man sollte sich in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft einfach klar machen, wenn wir einen Geheimdienst schaffen, haben wir da einen Bereich der Exekutive, einen Bereich quasi der Behörden, den wir nicht kontrollieren können. Das muss man so deutlich sagen. Das ist ein unkontrollierter Teil der Exekutive. Das kann man ja trotzdem noch wollen, wenn man das denn will. Aber man sollte sich zumindest nichts in die Tasche lügen, dass man mit irgendwelchen Kontrollgremien ernsthaft darauf einwirken kann, was die tun oder nicht tun. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach Selbstbetrug. Man kann Geheimdienste wollen. Man muss sich dann aber darüber klar sein, man schafft da Beamte, die machen, was sie wollen, im Kern. Das muss man sich klarmachen. Die machen dann genau so viel, wie sie Geld bekommen, um das zu tun. Und man kann dann nur noch hoffen, dass sie das immer entlang der Leitlinien tun, die die jeweilige Regierung aufstellt. Und wenn man Pech hat, machen sie eben ganz andere Dinge. Das muss man sich klarmachen, wenn man diesen Preis als demokratische Gesellschaft zu zahlen bereit ist. Dann ist das eben so, das ist in der Demokratie eben so, wenn die Mehrheit des Bundestages zum Beispiel das so will. Aber man sollte einfach aufhören mit diesem Selbstbetrug, wir haben hier ein parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium, und deswegen halten sie sich immer an Recht und Gesetz. Also da hat ja die Bundesregierung gerade wieder ein wunderschönes Beispiel geliefert, also nicht nur der BND, sondern die Bundesregierung höchstoffiziell. Vor einigen Wochen, ich glaube sogar an der ersten Sitzung des NSN-Untersuchungsausschusses, waren ja drei hochrangige Juristen geladen, die sich mal geäußert haben, quasi zur Verfassungsmäßigkeit, das haben wir jetzt glaube ich gar nicht in unserer Liste, aber da kann man mal kurz einführen, zur Verfassungsmäßigkeit der Auslandsspionage durch den BND. Da war jetzt nicht irgendwer. Da war der ehemalige Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts von der Union benannt, Herr Papier, wenn man ihn kennt, ein ausgesprochen distinguierter und auch vom Habitus her sehr konservativer Herr. Dann war da Prof. Hoffmann Riehm da, der als Verfassungsrichter zuständig war, etwa ein Jahrzehnt für Datenschutz, also ein absoluter Kenner der Materie, der sich seit den 70er-Jahren mit Datenschutz beschäftigt. Dann war da Matthias Becker, Professor in Mannheim und ein Schüler von Herrn Hoffmann Riehm. Drei absolute Profis sitzen da und sind sich alle drei einig. Wobei einer davon, wie gesagt von der Union benannt, war ein Ernstkonservativer Verfassungsrechtler. Es sind sich alle einig, was der BND im Ausland macht, ist verfassungswidrig, weil der BND im Ausland ohne Rechtsgrundlage Telekommunikation überwacht. Und was macht die Bundesregierung? Sie sagt uns einfach, nö, sehen wir anders. Da können die drei Verfassungsrechtler reden, so viel sie wollen. Wir machen trotzdem weiter wie bisher. Und da muss man einfach sagen, das ist in einem solchen Maße überraschend, will ich mal ganz vorsichtig sagen. Da fällt einem einfach gar nichts mehr zu ein. Und das zeigt einfach, wir haben es hier mit einem Bereich unkontrollierter Exekutive zu tun. Und aber auch mit einer Bundesregierung, die das aus irgendeinem Grunde will. Und ich finde, das ist die eigentlich spannende Frage. Warum wollen die das? Sind die selber alle vor Angst erstarrt, weil die BND-Leute sie sonst keine Ahnung an die Presse liefern? Haben die alle quasi ihre schwarzen Dosiers? Oder ist das letzten Endes nur eine Fantasie aus irgendwelchen Geheimdienstfilmen? Glauben die zum Beispiel, dass es für die Sicherheit unseres Landes zwingend erforderlich ist, dass der BND macht, was er macht? Ich würde es wirklich gerne wissen, was die Motivation der entscheidenden Leute im Bundeskanzleramt ist, über diese Argumentation der drei Verfassungsrechtler einfach so hinwegzugehen. Das hat mich wirklich überrascht, mit welcher Schutzbe, die das im Grunde gemacht haben, mit welcher Dreistigkeit das einfach so vom Tisch gewischt wird. Jetzt sehen wir anders.
So läuft das. Es nimmt einem natürlich auch immer wieder ein bisschen den Spaß weg, auf solche Sachen zu blinken. Deswegen ist es schön, dass dann auch manchmal spaßige Dinge passieren, wo man sich darüber freut. Die Firma Gamma bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon häufig diskutiert als der Hersteller, Dienstanbieter des Staatstrojaners Fynn Fischer und weiterer dieses Portfolio ergänzender Maßnahmen zum Angriff auf Computersysteme. Wir haben das, glaube ich, schon häufiger gesprochen, was Gamma so macht. Ich erinnere mich ja daran, dass ich schon vor langer Zeit prophezeit habe, dass die auch der Lieferant des zukünftigen deutschen Staatstrojaners irgendwann einmal sein werden. Im Moment befindet sich ihr Produkt ja in einer ausführlichen Testphase durch das BKA, wenn ich mich da jetzt nicht täusche. Die haben für 100.000 Euro oder 120.000 Euro, ein paar zerquetschte, eine Testlizenz dieses Produktes, mit der sie dann da jetzt gemeinsam mit Gamma daran arbeiten möchten, dieses Produkt in seinem Funktionsumfang so zu beschränken, dass es den gesetzlichen Vorgaben in Deutschland genügt. Gleichzeitig wird dieses Produkt in vielen Ländern dieser Welt eingesetzt. Und wie sich herausstellt, haben sie eine interne Support-Seite für ihre Kunden aus den vielen verschiedenen Ländern, wo es so etwas gibt, wie ein Kontakt-Formular, ein Support-Formular, wo man dann Support-Anfragen stellen kann. Da gibt es auf diesem Webserver neue Versionen der Software, die dort bereit liegen für die Kunden. Irgendjemand hat diese Büchs aufgemacht, 40 GB rausgezogen und als Torrent ins Internet gestellt. Er hat noch eine kleine Anleitung für Anfänger geschrieben. Er hat sich einen Twitter-Account gemacht. Gammapr hat von da aus etwas über den Hack berichtet. Aus Sicht von Gamma. finsupport.gamma.international.com ist down. It seems like we had a breach. Kurz darauf auf GitHub Teile des FinWeb-Sourcecodes veröffentlicht. Da liegt jetzt ein riesen Haufen Daten. Allerdings, was diese 40 Gigabyte versprachen, da hab ich gedacht, da werden wir ja Jahre dran rum analysieren. Für den größeren Teil dieser Daten sieht es nicht danach aus, dass wir analysieren werden, sondern kryptanalysieren werden. Denn der größere Teil der Daten ist leider verschlüsselt. Und so wie es aussieht, auch mit vernünftigen Verfahren. Noch dazu kommt, dass diese Support-Datenbank, die ich mir dann mal in den letzten Tagen genauer angeschaut habe, auch so angelegt ist, dass sie zumindest von der Datenbahnstruktur her keinen Rückschluss auf die Personen erlaubt. Das heißt, jeder einzelne Kunde ist dort mit der gleichen E-Mail-Adresse registriert, nämlich einer, die gamma selber gehört. Das heißt, die einzelnen Support-Nutzer haben anonyme Accounts und müssen also dann erst mal dumm sein, um sich zu verraten. Nämlich, indem sie zum Beispiel Ländernamen erwähnen. Das ist natürlich dann nicht besonders klug. Da habe ich mal so ein bisschen durchgeschaut. Aber weil ich das lieber den Leuten überlassen möchte, die seit langer Zeit spezifische Recherchen in Richtung gamma machen, möchte ich da jetzt nicht so viel zu vorwegnehmen oder so viel interpretieren von dem, was ich da gesehen habe. Es waren auf jeden Fall viele asiatische Länder, die da drin vorkamen. Vietnam, Bahrain waren also Ländernamen, die dann erwähnt wurden von diesen Kunden, die also sagten, hier in Bahrain gestaltet sich die Situation folgendermaßen. Und damit die eigentlich sehr gute OBSSEC, die gamma da betrieben hat. Ich meine, gut, die wissen natürlich auch Bescheid. Dann doch noch mal es geschafft haben, die zu unterwandern. Es sind außerdem dann bestimmte Entwickler, die da offensichtlich für gamma gearbeitet haben, enttarnt worden. Das waren aber dann, wenn man sich das Profil dieser Person angeschaut hat, auch keine so großen Überraschungen mehr. Das heißt, da steht jetzt keiner mit heruntergezogener Hose da, der nicht schon früher keinen Hehl daraus gemacht hätte, auf einer Seite der Macht zu stehen, die von moralisch gefestigten Menschen dann doch eher abgelehnt wird. Also ich hoffe, dass da noch mehr gefunden wird in diesem Leak. Aber ich muss sagen, die erste Euphorie muss ich dann doch eher mal ein bisschen bremsen. Aber wie gesagt, bei Rheinwatch und so, da kommen natürlich jetzt Sachen hoch. Aber nur weil da jetzt jemand im Support-Forum Holger heißt, bin ich mir halt noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass das dann auch sich um eine deutsche Person handelt und nicht vielleicht um einen schwedischen Kollegen oder so. Also da ist jetzt aufgrund der doch nennenswerten Obseck von Gamma noch einiges an Recherche notwendig. Das heißt, der große Knall bleibt da jetzt dann leider doch aus. Und auch die Executables, das wäre also was gewesen, womit man der Firma dann wirklich sehr schönen Schaden zufügen könnte. Nämlich die Trojaner-Versionen. Wenn du jetzt diesen aktuellen Trojaner hättest und den mal an alle Virenscanner-Hersteller schickst, dann kannst du halt mal wirklich auf den Tisch hauen. Damit kannst du Gamma halt out of business bringen und gleichzeitig auch alle Länder erkennen, in denen dieser Trojaner zum Einsatz kommt, wenn du da dann entsprechende Fünde hättest.
Einfach mal bei Virus total hochladen.
Genau, aber leider sind da auch Verschlüsselungsmethoden zum Einsatz gekommen, die eventuell nicht zu brechen sind. Da muss die Analyse noch weiter gehen, aber da müssen wir jetzt halt mal gucken.
Ich sag mal, wenn die ihr Handwerk verstehen, wird die Gruppe so ohne Weiteres nicht zu knacken sein, oder?
Also es sieht danach aus, dass die sich da schon durchaus Gedanken gemacht haben.
Es sei denn, es liegt mal jemand dem Secret Key?
Üblicherweise gibt es ja dann irgendwo nochmal einen Fehler. Also der muss halt jetzt mal gefunden werden. Wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass da einige Gruppierungen dran sind, sich das genauer anzuschauen. Ich habe da nur mal irgendwie ein, zwei Tage durchgeschaut und stehe da auch mit ein paar Leuten ein bisschen in Kontakt. Und ich hoffe mal, dass sich da noch was Schöneres draus ergibt. Aber nach den ersten Tagen herrscht erst mal noch so ein bisschen Ernüchterung, weil es doch nicht so einfach war, wie man sich das vielleicht erhofft hatte.
Aber gut, ich meine, bei 40 Gigabyte könnte ja zum Beispiel so etwas wie eine Known Plain Text Attacke funktionieren. Man hat ja bestimmte Dateien im Klartext. Und wenn die sich jetzt noch mal verschlüsselt irgendwo in dieser Fundgrube finden, das wäre doch schon mal sehr schön.
Ja, aber eine Known Plain Text Attacke auf 40 Gig?
Nein, natürlich nicht auf die 40 Gig. Sondern wenn da jetzt bestimmte Dateien im Plain Text da sind, aber auch noch mal verschlüsselt, wäre natürlich ein Geschenk des Himmels.
Ja, aber Known Plain Text Angriffe sind auch nur auf bestimmte Schiffrinder wirklich eine gangbare Methode.
Schauen wir mal.
Das wird natürlich den Ruf dieser Firma nachhaltig schädigen. Das wird in einigen Ländern auch noch mal für Debatten sorgen. Wobei ich auch überrascht war, wie weit der Stand inzwischen ist von Ländern, von denen man wusste, dass sie diese Software zum Einsatz bringen. Zum Beispiel war Belgien für mich ein Fund, wo ich aufgeschrien habe und dachte, ich habe etwas Neues, aber das steht also schon seit einiger Zeit zur Debatte. Andererseits natürlich auch zu sagen, man sieht auch hier wieder, d.h. auch jene, von denen man immer wusste, die können es wirklich. Im Gegensatz zu Digitask, die die Praktikanten dürfen ran, die da dieses My First, My Wear abgeliefert haben, da sind andere Leute zugange. Und auch die fallen irgendwann mal zum Opfer. Das ist natürlich auch vielleicht nochmal ein Argument, was wir in Zukunft im politischen Kampf gegen Staatstrojaner bringen müssen.
Es gibt einfach kein sicheres System, das muss man einfach so deutlich sagen. Das muss man sich selber klar machen, wenn man Systeme betreibt. Und es gibt nur relativ sichere Systeme oder relativ unsichere Systeme. Und das politische Argument, das haben wir doch hier alles gesichert. Und das zählt einfach nicht mehr. Man muss immer vom Worst Case her denken, genau wie bei Atomkraftwerken auch. Ein Atomkraftwerk kann man nur dann betreiben, wenn es sogar dann noch in Ordnung wäre, wenn es um uns in die Ohren fliegt. Und das hat ja inzwischen sogar Angela Merkel eingesehen, dass das jedenfalls in Deutschland nicht funktionieren kann. Und im Prinzip ist es mit Starten der Malware ganz genau dasselbe.
Ja, was für mich noch aus technischer Sicht ganz interessant war, dass sie Probleme haben, iOS-Geräte zu infizieren.
Ja, das fand ich auch faszinierend. Dass sie es über Jahre hinweg anscheinend nicht geschafft haben, irgendeinen Zero-Day einzukaufen, der dann eben nicht gefunden wird. Das fand ich auch wirklich faszinierend. Denn immerhin, die Jailbreak-Szene hat es ja mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen geschafft, jede einzelne iOS-Version zu knacken.
Du kannst natürlich auch das, was Jailbreak ist, kannst du natürlich auch als Infektionsvektor wieder nutzen, wenn dieser Jailbreak eben Drive-By ist. Aber das war, glaube ich, seit iOS 4, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Das war eine PDF-Datei, die einmal komplett rausgeklettert ist aus allen Sandboxes.
Das war unglaublich krass. Das werde ich nie vergessen. Das wollte ich dann doch mal probieren. Da stand ich vor dem Oberholz. Irgendwie habe ich das Oberholz-W-Lan von außen angezapft. Und habe gesagt, jetzt willst du es mal wissen. Und dann hat es erstmal ein paar Minuten gedauert, weil der Server natürlich mehr oder weniger down war. Aber irgendwann habe ich die PDF gekriegt und zack, boom, ein Reboot. Und ich hatte ein Jailbroken-iPhone. So einfach war es echt noch nie.
Genau, und das ist natürlich der absolute Goldfund der Security-Szene, wo du eben auch aus sehr, sehr hohen Preisen für erzielen kannst. Wenn du sowas schaffst für iOS 7 oder gar 8, da kannst du halt wirklich sechs- bis siebenstädtige Beträge vielleicht sogar für bekommen.
Also iOS 8 wird natürlich an der Stelle viel mehr Angriffsfläche bieten durch die erweiterten Möglichkeiten, die man als Programmierer bekommt. Es gibt ja jetzt unter iOS 8 erstmals, oder wird es geben, die Möglichkeit zum Beispiel quasi Shared Libraries zu entwickeln. Also zum Beispiel Tastaturen wird es geben, aber auch Plug-Ins quasi, die es ermöglichen aus App 1 in App 2 irgendwelche Daten direkt zu übermitteln. Also angeblich hat Apple da ein ziemlich gutes Sandbox-System entwickelt, dass die Shared Libraries trotzdem eben jeweils in einer Sandbox gefangen bleiben. Und sie entwickeln das auch schon parallel seit iOS 6 mit. Das konnte man also anscheinend in dem Code irgendwie nachweisen. Habe ich noch nicht mal einen längeren Blogpost gelesen. Aber auch wenn sie da seit zwei Jahren dran hacken, ist es natürlich einfach eine völlig neue Technologie. Und ich könnte mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass da in iOS 8.0 einfach erstmal irgendwas schief gegangen ist.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, weil du hast natürlich zwei Probleme. Du willst irgendwie Jailbreaken, du musst aus den Sachen rausklettern, du musst aber andererseits natürlich diese Code-Signing-Sache noch hinkriegen. Und das ist ja der eigentliche wirklich tiefliegende Grund, warum iOS so sicher ist gegen diese Standard-Mailware, die wir im Android-Bereich so viel sehen, ist eigentlich, dass Apple halt seinen Kopierschutz von vornherein ordentlich gemacht hat. Und dieser gesamte Malware-Schutz ist ein Fuß zu mindestens 60 Prozent auf dem ordentlich gemachten Code-Signing, was es eben dann auch verhindert für einen Angreifer, die jetzt irgendwie eine manipulierte App unterzuschieben und dich so dazu zu bringen, dir vielleicht freiwillig einen Trojaner oder einen J-Break zu installieren, was bei Android ja aufgrund verschiedener Implementierungsfehler dann immer wieder mal möglich war. Noch dazu ruten die Leute ihre Telefoner sowieso freiwillig. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr genau, wer es gesagt hat, aber es war, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht war es sogar TheGruk oder so, der sagte, dass das iPhone eventuell als der sicherste Computer zu bezeichnen ist, den es so jemals gegeben hat als trusted platform. Natürlich, dann schreien natürlich alle los, klar, natürlich heißt das nicht, dass nicht trotzdem Apple eure Daten in der iCloud analysiert und Apple mit allen möglichen Behörden zusammenarbeitet und die Flughafenvögel am US-Flughafen, wenn sie euer Telefon mal kurz sehen wollen, ob es denn auch funktioniert und dann mal einen USB-Kabel dranhalten, das Ding nicht trotzdem innerhalb von einer halben Sekunde ownen und eure Daten daraus kratzen. Das heißt es nicht, aber für den Normalbürger, der dessen Sorge jetzt vielleicht eher der Angriff des Nachbarn ist, scheint das also eine sehr stabile Plattform zu sein. Und es war natürlich erfreulich zu hören, dass Gamma sich da auch die Zähne dran ausbeißen, solange es nicht jailbroken ist. Vor allem, weil Gamma, das war auch ein Ergebnis dieses Leaks, auch bei Wuppenkauf, das ist diese französische Zero-Day-Bude, die wir auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon öfter kritisiert haben oder angeprangert haben, die also eben diesen Schwarzmarkt unterhält und gangbar macht, ist also diesen Handel für Geheimdienste überhaupt ermöglicht. Aber das geht jetzt vielleicht noch mal zu weit. Da haben wir schon mal eine längere Folge zu gemacht. Ich verlink die noch mal. Auf jeden Fall denke ich, als politische Maßnahme ist irgendwie notwendig, eben das auch zu verhindern, dass dieser Handel mit Sicherheitslücken, mit Malware so floriert. Und hier natürlich nur von Regierungen angeheizt wird. Das heißt, die Regierungen sind es, die diese Staatstrojaner haben wollen. Die Regierungen sind es, die die Sicherheitslücken, die diese Staatstrojaner für ihre Infektionswege ausnutzen, weiterhin bestehen bleiben. Die Regierungen sind es, die hier aktiv gegen die Sicherheit der Bürger arbeiten. Denn eine Sicherheitslücke, die existiert, steht prinzipiell erstmal allen zur Verfügung. Und daran ändert es auch nichts, dass sie komplexer ist. Denn es gibt immer noch genauso hohe finanzielle Anreize, diese Sicherheitslücken auf anderen Wegen auszunutzen. Mit anderen Motivationen als nur, um Terroristen zu jagen.
Das muss man wohl so sehen. In diesem Kontext finde ich es auch gerade wieder so spannend, dass es eben jetzt diesen Leak gegeben hat. Du hast schon gesagt, es ist nicht so richtig klar, wie viel Daten wir wirklich aus diesen 40 Gigabyte rauskratzen können. Aber jedes System ist hackbar, das hatten wir schon. Aber das bedeutet natürlich zugleich, dass ich als Kunde von einer solchen Bude auch immer damit rechnen muss, dass ich morgen in der Zeitung stehe und damit auch in meinem eigenen Land am Pranger stehe. Das finde ich, also diese gesunde Unsicherheit, dass die Bad Guys einfach damit rechnen müssen, dass es eben doch mal rauskommt und dass sie sich eben doch rechtfertigen müssen. Diese Unsicherheit ist eigentlich Gold wert. Das ist im Grunde fast wichtiger, als dass jetzt irgendwie noch die letzte Executable-Datei entschlüsselt werden kann. Ich denke, für die Politiker ist es einfach jedenfalls in demokratischen Staaten ein wahnsinnig hoher Preis, den sie zahlen müssen.
Aber für die Täter, ich habe zum Beispiel auch überlegt, ob ich nicht einfach jetzt mal schön einfach die Namen der in den einzelnen Ländern befindlichen Projektkoordinatoren für diese Staatstruaner veröffentliche.
Die standen da drin, dieser Service-Datei.
Einige Personen waren halt so blöd, ihre Namen da zu nennen.
Das war quasi so ein Chat-Protokoll.
Da ist dann so eine Support-Anfrage und dann schreibt einer, ich kriege übrigens euer Newsletter immer noch auf meine alte Adresse, so und so, at telenet.be, ändert das mal auf meine neue Holger, so und so. Und das wäre natürlich, jetzt wird es sicherlich auch geschehen, ich habe halt gedacht, dass ich es mal nicht mache, aber es wäre natürlich schön, auch diese Menschen dann auch mal rauszuzerren und zu sagen, hier, das ist übrigens der Projektkoordinator für den Staatstrojaner in folgendem Land. Sagt dem doch mal, hier ist die E-Mail-Adresse, könnt ihr dem ja mal sagen, was ihr davon haltet. Das ist natürlich dreckig, das ist unsauber, damit bringt man jetzt nicht seine moralische Überlegenheit zum Ausdruck, indem man zu solchen Methoden greift. Was dann auch die Erwägung war, warum ich das jetzt in dem Fall nicht gemacht habe oder darauf warte, dass es jemand anders macht. Andererseits ist es natürlich wichtig, dass die auch Angst kriegen. Wenn sie schon irgendwie in diesen allmächtigen Positionen liegen und unseren Rechtsstaat ignorieren, wobei ich das jetzt für jedes einzelne dieser Länder nicht weiß, ob das eine Verletzung der Verfassung ist, die da stattfindet, dann kann man sich natürlich wünschen, dass sie sich wenigstens fürchten. Andererseits wird diese Furcht der Täter oder auch dieser ganzen Geheimdienstmitarbeiter natürlich jetzt dadurch gestillt, dass Personen wie Chelsea Manning oder auch Edward Snowden möglichst hochgehängt werden. Die müssen absolut drakonisch bestraft werden, an denen müssen Exempel statuiert werden, an denen darf kein gutes Haar gelassen werden, damit sie eben keine Nachahmer finden. Und damit jene, die mit dem Gedanken spielen, vielleicht ihnen zu folgen. Oder jene, die vor einem zweiten Edward Snowden sich fürchten oder Angst haben, irgendwann zur Rechenschaft gezogen zu werden, eben weiter so funktionieren, wie es ihre Jobdescription ist. Deswegen weiß ich eben auch nicht, ob diese individuelle Rechenschaft dann wirklich der große Hebel ist, den wir haben.
Ich weiß es auch nicht so richtig. Aber es ist immer noch meine Hoffnung, dass es diese Furcht gibt bei all denen, die quasi die Grenzen überschreiten. Oder andersrum, natürlich ist es einfach viel leichter, Sauerreihen im Dunkeln anzustellen. Und je größer aus diesem Schwarz ein Grau wird, oder vielleicht sogar hier und da mal ein richtiger Lichtstrahl, desto größer ist vielleicht dann doch die Motivation, im entscheidenden Moment zu sagen, ne, also Leute, lass uns das doch mal auf eine saubere Weise machen. Lass uns doch mal nicht diese Gruselsoftware kaufen, sondern lass uns doch mal darauf dringen, dass die eben bestimmte Grenzen anhält. Ich weiß es nicht, wie da auch die Anreizstrukturen sind in solchen Diensten. Ob da also die Furcht vor Entdeckung größer ist oder irgendwie die Lust, Karriere zu machen. Das sind ja, hoffe ich, die ganz banalen Gründe, die dazu führen, dass Leute so über die Stränge schlagen oder irgendwelche Selbstrechtfertigungsstrategien, wie wir stehen ja auf der richtigen Seite. Das ist jetzt zwar vielleicht illegal, aber es ist ja quasi für die gute Sache und so weiter. Ich weiß es nicht, was da letztlich durchschlägt, aber ich denke, man kann gar nicht genug Furcht erzeugen bei denjenigen, die selber einfach das Recht brechen.
Kennst du eigentlich die TV-Serie 24? Nein. Das ist mal eine interessante Lektion in US-Verfassungsaufarbeitung. Das ist irgendwie mit diesem Kiefer Sutherland. Der ist ja irgendwie so eine Terroristenbekämpfungseinheit. Es ist eine unglaublich spannende Serie in Echtzeit. Die Sendung heißt 24. Sie besteht aus 24 Folgen. Die 24 Folgen sind jeweils eine Stunde lang. Wenn man sie ohne Werbung schaut, sind es 45 Minuten. Dieser Mann prügelt und foltert sich nur durch den Tag, um einen Terroranschlag zu verhindern. Ich glaube, die sind im Moment der 8. Das ist eine enorm erfolgreiche Sendung, die seit Jahren in den USA gezeigt wird. Als Zuschauer denkst du, der muss gerade verhindern, dass die Atombombe mitten in New York hochgeht. Es ist ganz klar, dass er nicht darauf Rücksicht nehmen kann, dass bei dem Folterverhör ein Anwalt anwesend sein muss. Das ist sehr spannend, wie in den letzten Jahren dieses Gefühl für den Rechtsstaat in einer Unterhaltungssendung, die Millionen Zuschauer erreicht und unglaublich spannend ist, auch sukzessive abgebaut wird. Das kann man sehr schön an dieser Sendung sehen. Ich hab das, glaube ich, nicht gesehen. Aber irgendwann, so spätestens ab der dritten Staffel, bist du dann auch da, jetzt hau dem doch mal ein.
Das muss doch jetzt mal rauszukriegen sein.
Genau, den Bösen muss doch jetzt mal abknallen. Natürlich verraten die sich da alle gegenseitig. Aber das ist ja so ein sehr schönes Propagandating. Kann man sich echt mal anschauen. Aber da muss man wirklich mit einer, muss man sich auch immer wieder auf seine Distanz als Beobachter zurückziehen. Kommen wir mal zum nächsten Thema. Das war etwas, das war etwas, das fand ich großartig. Da habe ich Tränen gelacht. Es ging los mit der Meldung. Google hat also einen 41-jährigen Texaner an die Behörden ausgeliefert. Dieser Mann hatte per Gmail ein Bild versandt. Und dieses Bild war offensichtlich ein kinderpornografisches Bild. Also dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch oder eine minderjährige Person, die da abgebildet war. Und Google hat also auf seinen Servern eine Liste mit Prüfsummen liegen von bekanntem Material dieser Art. Und hat also die E-Mails dieses Texaners gescannt, wie sie natürlich auch alle anderen E-Mails scannen ihrer Kunden, um daraus irgendwie die entsprechenden Werbeeinblendungen an der Seite zu machen. Und hat diesen Mensch dann eben den Behörden ausgeliefert. Der wurde verhaftet und blickt jetzt einem Urteil entgegen. War natürlich eine Meldung wert, dass dein E-Mail-Provider offensichtlich da das Postgeheimnis nicht war. Wobei das jetzt bei Google natürlich auch nicht besonders überraschend ist. Wenige Tage später gab es dann eine Meldung, dass Microsoft einen ähnlichen Menschen also ausgeliefert hat oder gemeldet hat. Nämlich an das National Center for Missing and Exploited Children. Und dieses National Center for Missing and Exploited Children arbeitet also seit einiger Zeit schon sehr erfolgreich mit Microsoft zusammen. Dabei handelte es sich um eine Person, die dieses Bild in dem Microsoft OneDrive gespeichert hatte. Und das National Center for Missing and Exploited Children hat also dann von dort der Polizei gemeldet. Auch diese Person wurde dann eben dem Strafprozess zugeführt. Und dann, nachdem also die US-amerikanischen E-Mail-Anbieter da jetzt in den Medien waren und vermeintlich schlechte Presse hatten als Anbieter, die die E-Mails ihrer Nutzer lesen, haben dann die deutschen E-Mail-Anbieter eine Pressemitteilung verfasst und über die dpa verbreiten lassen, die dann in der wunderschönen Schlagzeile gipfelte. Deutsche E-Mail-Anbieter durchsuchen Mails, nicht nach Kinderpornos. Na, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also, wie schön könnt ihr dafür werben, wie schön könnt ihr für euch selber werben, in diesem Moment natürlich das nicht ungenutzt zu lassen, euch zum Vollhorst zu machen und irgendwie dafür zu werben, dass man durch euch problemlos kinderpornografisches Material versetzen kann.
Da sind wir ja beruhigt, dass das noch irgendwo geht. Wobei man ja schon sagen muss, ich finde das zugleich schon spannend, dass auf diese Art und Weise doch mal in das Bewusstsein einer breiteren Öffentlichkeit geraten ist, dass Google alles durchliest und alles scannt und alles vermutlich indexiert. Google hat ja im Grunde das Erfolgsmodell des Indexieren des Webs und sie haben es irgendwie geschafft, das massiv zu parallelisieren. Die genauen technischen Details kennt ja im Grunde keiner, glaube ich, außerhalb von Google. Aber jedenfalls schaffen sie das. Und wir können mal davon ausgehen, dass unsere E-Mails im Grunde aus Googles Perspektive nichts anderes sind als so eine Art Internet. Und dass diese ganzen Daten, die eben unverschüsslich durch Googles Server laufen, einfach mal mitgeschnitten und indexiert werden und dass da eine ganze Menge an Profilbildung im Hintergrund stattfindet über uns alle. Also das merkt man ja schon, wenn einem dann irgendwelche Leute, mit denen man E-Mails austauscht, mit einmal auf Google+, wenn man sich da einmal im Jahr anmeldet, als mögliche Bekannte angeboten werden. Also das ist schon einigermaßen gruselig. Und ich habe leider auch einige Leute in meinem persönlichen Umfeld, die immer noch bei Gmail sind. Und ich sage denen dann immer, meine Güte, ich finde das total komisch. Wir schreiben uns hier mitunter persönliche E-Mails. Und du bist bei Gmail, was soll ich machen? Also ich möchte eigentlich, was ich dir schreibe, nicht auch Google schreiben. Aber die Leute sind dann unter Umständen einfach ziemlich dickfällig. Und sogar da sind auch teilweise Journalisten dabei, wo ich mich dann echt nur noch wundern kann. Ja, dass die das in Ordnung finden. Wie will man denn da investigativ arbeiten, wenn man Google alle seine Inhalte auf dem Silbertablett? Ja, ich meine, das ist doch absurd. Und dann schlägt man ihnen noch vor, es wäre vielleicht eine gute Idee, wenn wir vielleicht mal PGP einsetzen. Also das ist ja nicht immer ganz einfach. Ich habe da auch schon meine Fehler gemacht. Weil irgendwie, wenn es darum ging, ich habe mir neun Schlüssel angelegt und den alten revoked, ohne vorher den neuen zu signieren und so. War jetzt nicht so eine richtig coole Idee. Aber wie dem auch sei, PGP wäre ja meine Lösung. Oder GPG meint wegen auch. Aber selbst das wollen die Leute dann nicht. Und das muss ich sagen, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Denn es geht ja nicht nur um deren Privatsphäre. Ja, die können sie ja meinteilbem opfern. Aber sie opfern ja parallel dazu auch meine Privatsphäre. Oder es stellt mich jedenfalls vor, die Wahl, also entweder meine Privatsphäre Google zu opfern oder mit den Leuten nicht mehr zu kommunizieren. Und das muss ich eigentlich sagen, finde ich total ärgerlich. Na ja, da kann man wirklich nur an jeden appellieren. Sucht euch einen vernünftigen E-Mail-Provider. Wir haben ja in Berlin zum Beispiel zwei Firmen, also ich habe mit denen überhaupt keine geschäftliche Verbindung. Ich habe auch meinen eigenen E-Mail-Server. Aber das ist sicherlich eine gute Alternative.
Sich da mal irgendwas anderes zu wählen. Also jetzt natürlich nicht unbedingt jemanden von der Deutschen Telekom oder United Internet, die jetzt für diese tolle Meldung verantwortlich zeichnen. Nee, das ist vielleicht nicht die beste Idee. Aber ich fand das also... Ich war mir nicht sicher, ob die jetzt... Sind die so blöd? Dass das natürlich eine absolute Negativ-Schlagzeile ist? Oder haben sie die jetzt absichtlich platziert, um dann sich in einem zweiten Schritt dazu auffordern zu lassen, doch bitte die E-Mails ihrer Nutzer zu scannen? Aber wie du immer auch sagst, ich fand das nur so... Mann, das ist einfach hoffnungslos mit denen. In diesem Bereich ist das echt leider hoffnungslos, was die machen. Aber ich will mich ja schon gar nicht mehr mit E-Mails auseinandersetzen. Ich kriege da ja immer noch regelmäßig irgendwelche Fragen zu. Aber das fand ich, also diesen PR-Geniestreich. Durch uns kann man Kinderpornografie versenden. Vielen Dank die deutschen Internetanbieter.
Vielen Dank fürs Gespräch.
Kommen sie vom Google weg. Mit uns wäre ihnen das nicht passiert.
Krass, krass, krass. Das war sicherlich ein ganz besonderes kluger Move. Aber du hast schon recht. Das könnte der Versuch gewesen sein, eine weitere Steilvorlage für die Argumentation im politischen Raum zu schaffen. Nach dem Motto obligatorisches Scannen, nachdem die Idee mit den Internetsperren nicht so richtig gut geklappt hat, könnte man jetzt obligatorische E-Mailsperre diskutieren.
Also es gibt...
Völlig absurd, weil wahrscheinlich eine einfache ZIP-Datei spätestens mit Passwort...
Die entzipst du dann halt wieder.
Ja, aber mit Passwort?
Naja, Standard-ZIP-Verschlüsselung ist auch nicht brauchbar.
Ich dachte, das ist AES irgendwie.
Standard-ZIP-Verschlüsselung ist kein AES.
Aber es gibt doch... Ich glaube, da findet der gemeine Kriminelle dann schon irgendeine Lösung, wie das jedenfalls der Standard-Scan nicht mehr erfasst.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du krimineller bist, das ist ja auch das Traurige eigentlich. Also das ist das, was ich konstant an dieser ganzen Sache betraue. Der Kriminelle, der Terrorist, die Personen, vor denen wir uns wirklich jetzt zu fürchten haben. Oder vor denen, die ich jetzt nicht für eine große Bedrohung halte, aber die als einziger Grund für diese Existenz dieser ganzen geheimnäßlichen Maßnahmen herhalten müssen. Genau die, die nutzen doch keine Gmail-Konten oder die machen auch jetzt keinen Google-Wave auf, um ihren nächsten Anschlag zu planen. Also die wissen doch, die haben doch nun mal Obseck-Regeln. Die wissen doch, wie sie sich verhalten müssen. Die verschlüsseln selbstverständlich. Also es geht doch hier wirklich um diesen Beifang. Die Delfine haben längst gelernt, um dein Netz drum herum zu schwimmen. Aber die anderen Tierarten, die dann eben da drin landen...
Die Meeresschildkröten.
Die vergammeln da nämlich in der Netz.
Schlechtes Beispiel. Aber diese Maßnahmen, also wirklich erfolgreiche oder tatsächliche Bedrohungen und tatsächliche Kriminelle, die sind eben auch nicht so blöd.
Gut, da würde natürlich jeder Kriminaler mit einigem Recht gegenhalten. Na ja. So lange es noch so Blöde gibt. Ja, außer das zum einen. Und wir leben von Fehlern. Wir kriegen natürlich immer die Leute, die die Fehler machen. Ich finde das Argument einerseits ganz stichhaltig, auf der anderen Seite ist es auch nicht ganz so stark, wenn man es auf den ersten Blick annimmt. Denn das ist schon in der Tat eine der Hauptstärken, dass den allermeisten Leuten irgendwelche Fehler passieren. Zum Beispiel dieser Superhacker aus New York, der irgendwie breite Kreise bei Anonymous unter seinen Fittichen hatte. Sabu. Den haben sie ja auch nur deswegen gekriegt und dann unter Druck gesetzt und umgedreht vom FBI, weil er sich einmal, ein einziges Mal, ohne Tor in seinem ICQ-Channel eingeloggt hat. Nicht IC. Genau, weil das FBI genügend IC-Server unter seiner Kontrolle hatte, dass sie dann irgendwie die IP zuordnen konnten. Der hat einen einzigen Fehler gemacht. Und schon hatten sie ihn am Wickel und haben ihn dann ja dazu gezwungen, längere Zeit quasi gegen seine einzigen Buddys da mitzuarbeiten. Also das ist schon, finde ich, ein ganz interessanter Fall. Selbst ziemliche Profis machen eben doch irgendwann mal Fehler. Aber trotzdem hast du natürlich recht, dass dieses Argument, es geht ja nur um Terroristen, nicht so wahnsinnig stichhaltig ist. Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung war das nach den Statistiken, die wir aus Österreich gelesen haben, jedenfalls Bullshit. Also die Österreicher haben keinen einzigen Terroristen gefangen. Ein paar andere Kriminelle sicherlich, aber eben keinen einzigen Terroristen.
Österreich ist ja jetzt auch nicht das Epizentrum des terroristischen Interesses.
Das sicherlich sowieso nicht, aber immerhin haben wir da mal Statistiken, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung tatsächlich gebracht hat.
Mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind wir dann auch wieder bei den deutschen Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Und da finde ich ja sehr schön, dass die Methode der stillen SMS, da sind wir ja so ein bisschen in meinem technischen Fachbereich, vielleicht um die nochmal zu erklären, quasi in dem Standard SMS, also wie eine SMS-Nachricht auszusehen hat, wenn sie an dein Handy kommt und wie dieses Handy diese Nachricht zu verarbeiten hat, gibt es verschiedene Typen von Nachrichten. Und nur einer dieser Typen ist derjenige, der dann auch wirklich dargestellt wird als Nachricht an dich, wo das Handy sagt, das ist eine Nachricht an den Nutzer, die gebe ich jetzt mal dem Hauptprozessor weiter, der passt den Text, der da drin steht, piept dann entsprechend und zeigt diese Nachricht dem Nutzer an. Es gibt aber auch eine SMS vom Typ 0, bei der dann das standardgemäße Verhalten des Telefones ist, den Empfang dieser Nachricht zu bestätigen, dem Nutzer aber keinerlei Hinweis darüber zu geben, dass hier gerade eine Transaktion stattgefunden hat. Es gibt dann noch weitere SMS-Typen, die zum Beispiel von der SIM-Karte verarbeitet werden. Da gab es vor einem Jahr eine ganz interessante Präsentation zu, zu Sicherheitslücken in diesem Bereich, aber da schweife ich schon wieder ab. Aber quasi diesen GSM oder im SMS, in der Definition dieses Standards, entwickelten Typen der Testnachricht vom Typ 0. Der wird seit einigen Jahren, vielleicht sogar schon seit Jahrzehnten, von den deutschen Behörden ausgenutzt, um Restriktionen der deutschen Gesetzgebung zu umgehen. Nämlich, dass die GSM-Netzte genau nicht dazu nutzen dürfen, Menschen die ganze Zeit zu triangulieren und ihren Weg nachzuverfolgen. Was sie aber dürfen, ist sich am Ende des Monats die Transaktionsdaten dieser Menschen abholen. Und was also die deutschen Strafverfolgungsbehörden dann machen, ist, dass sie bestimmten Zielpersonen einfach in gegebenen Zeitintervallen immer wieder so eine SMS zusenden, die vom Telefon nicht verarbeitet und der Empfang bestätigt wird, jedoch die Nachricht im Nutzer nicht angezeigt wird, um dann eben am Ende sich diese gesamte Transaktionsliste von dem Mobilfunkanbieter geben zu lassen. Und da steht dann eben auch drin, wo sich die Person oder in welcher Zelle sich die Person zu diesem Zeitpunkt befunden hat. Und das ist also der Hintergrund zu dieser stillen SMS, die ich also als einen Hack am Gesetz interpretiere. Interpretierst du das auch so, oder habe ich da jetzt diese Methode falsch interpretiert?
Das ist wirklich sehr lustig. Diese technischen Details kannte ich jetzt auch nicht ganz so im Detail. Mir war halt im Grunde nur klar, jetzt eher so aus der praktisch-rechtlichen Perspektive, dass man mit diesem Versenden von stillen SMS im Grunde Einträge in der Liste der Funkzellenabfrage provoziert. Weil beim Empfang dieser SMS das Handy tatsächlich mal mit der Basisstation funken muss. Insofern weiß man dann nicht nur, in welcher Location Area das gerade rumrennt, sondern man weiß dann eben auch diese Funkzelle und im Zweifel sogar noch dieser Abstand.
Genau.
Das provoziert man eben bewusst, indem man diese stillen SMS versendet.
Das Telefon ist deinem Anbieter. Naja, der Anbieter weiß schon ziemlich genau, wo du die ganze Zeit bist.
Aber halt nur auf der Basis der Location Area.
Der weiß grob, in welcher Region du bist. Der weiß nicht immer unbedingt genau, in welcher Zelle du bist. Aber das wäre jetzt auch kein Problem, das zu flaggen und einfach mitzuzeichnen. Aber das scheint mir, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, gesetzlich eben nicht erlaubt zu sein. Das heißt, sie dürfen nur diese tatsächlich angefallenen Verkehrsdaten abrufen. Und weil sie Menschen eben darüber trecken wollen, müssen sie dafür sorgen, dass es eben ganz, ganz viele stille Transaktionen gibt, von denen der Nutzer nichts mitbekommen hat. So funktioniert die stille SMS. Die Nachricht ist jetzt, das BKA hat in den ersten sechs Monaten dieses Jahres 35.000 solcher Kurzmitteilungen versendet, die Bundespolizei 69.000. Und das sind jeweils so ungefähr 3000 mehr als im ersten Halbjahr 2013. Jetzt sagt diese Anzahl aber leider überhaupt nichts aus, darüber, wie viele Personen dann Ziel dieser Maßnahme sind. Denn die Nachrichten werden in einem zeitlichen Intervall gesendet, üblicherweise vielleicht auch nur ab und zu mal, wenn man sich wirklich interessiert. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht, wie viele Nutzer tatsächlich Ziel dieser Maßnahme sind. Aber die Anzahlen sind natürlich schon ganz nennenswert. Und ich denke mal, wenn man ein normales Bewegungsprofil einer Person sieht, dann reicht vielleicht so ein 5- oder 10-Minuten-Abstand zu entscheidenden Zeiten, da mal so eine SMS zu senden. Telekommunikationsüberwachungsmaßnahmen in der ersten Jahreshälfte vom BKA 704 Mal. Ist das eine hohe Zahl oder wie würdest du das beurteilen?
Das finde ich persönlich jetzt nicht so extrem viel. Wenn man sich mal überlegt, dass wir ja über 20.000 TKÜ-Maßnahmen haben normalerweise im Jahr, also TKÜ im Sinne von Telefonabhören, was heutzutage fast immer Handyabhören bedeutet, dann finde ich 704 Mal vom BKA jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Aber auch da gilt im Grunde ähnlich wie bei der stillen SMS. Man weiß halt einfach nicht, wie viele Beschuldigte waren das jetzt, wie viele Ermittlungsverfahren waren das. Man weiß halt nur, 704 Beschlüsse hat es anscheinend gegeben. Und jedenfalls weiß ich das aus dem wichtigsten Anwendungsbereich von TKÜ, das ist heutzutage die Drogenkriminalität, dass da in einem Ermittlungsverfahren 20, 30 Beschlüsse schnell zusammenkommen, einfach weil der typische Dealer 7 SIM-Karten im Wechsel verwendet und 8 Handys.
Ach und der Beschluss ist immer pro Zielruf, pro MSISDN, also pro Zielrufnummer, nicht pro Person.
Ganz genau, und gegebenenfalls auch mal pro E-Mail, also pro Gerätenummer. Aber im Kern musst du halt ständig neue Beschlüsse machen, wenn die Leute ihre Handys oder ihre SIM-Karten wechseln. Und aus diesem Grunde sagt die Zahl der Maßnahmen nicht so wahnsinnig viel darüber aus, wie viele Ermittlungsverfahren da dran hängen und wie viele Beschuldigte da dran hängen.
Und dann gab es noch eine Zahl zur Funkzellenabfrage. Bei der Funkzellenabfrage geht es genau andersrum. Das heißt, da tracken wir nicht eine Zielperson vorher mit SMS, sondern wir fragen den Provider, welche Geräte, also welche SIM-Karten, welche Telefone und damit natürlich letztendlich welche Personen zu einem gewissen Zeitraum in einem gewissen Bereich eingebucht waren. Das ist dann schon sehr genau, also eine Funkzelle ist immer, je nachdem wie man jetzt die Funkzelle definiert, ist es entweder ein 120 Grad Abstrahlwinkel von der Antenne, weil die immer so drei Segmente haben.
Also bei O2 jedenfalls, oder machen die das alle so?
Ja, das bei allen so. In der Regel sind das so dreimal 120 Grad.
Ich komme ja vom Lande, da hatte die Telekom früher diese Rundstrahler, diese Umbrella-Zellen, weißt du?
Vielleicht habe ich das jetzt übergeneralisiert von meiner Erfahrung, aber üblicherweise hast du eine Zelle im urbanen Rahmen, die ist dann eher noch mal aufgeteilt in drei, die in jede Richtung noch mal strahlen. Aber es kann sein, dass das auch in ländlichen Regionen dann noch mal anders ist. Aber letztendlich heißt es, es gibt eine Antenne. Jede einzelne Antenne, die da irgendwie steht, hat eine Cell-ID. Du gibst dann eine geografische Region den Providern, du sagst, ich möchte von allen Zellen, die in diesem Bereich, diese geografische Region abdecken, gerne mal wissen, wer da zu einem gewissen Zeitraum eingebucht war. War natürlich ein großes Thema, dass der André Meister ja hauptsächlich bei AKT ja auch regelmäßig bei uns Gast ist. Und zum ersten Mal so richtig laut wurde das Thema eben im Rahmen der Gegendemonstration zu dem Nazi-Aufmarsch in Dresden vor, inzwischen wahrscheinlich auch drei Jahren oder zwei Jahren. Nee, der Aufmarsch vor drei Jahren, das Thema vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich. Aber okay, ich schweige schon wieder ab. Also Funkzellenabfrage 50 von der Bundespolizei in der ersten Jahreshälfte, drei vom BKA, Zoll 100 Mal. Das deckt sich, jetzt frage ich mich, was macht der Zoll? Also warum macht der Zoll das? Mit der Funkzellenabfrage gibt es eigentlich zwei Methoden, zwei Methoden, die da zum Fahnenungserfolg führen. Einmal natürlich, du möchtest einfach alle Menschen wissen, die irgendwie bei dieser Nazi-Demo gegen demonstriert haben, um dein Extremistenregister zu füllen. Das ist so die eine Methode. Die vielversprechendere oder auf eine Weise gezielter und kriminalistisch reizvollere Methode ist natürlich, wenn du einen Serientäter hast, wie du in Berlin ja letztes Jahr war das, so wurde der, glaube ich, irgendwann gefasst. Ein frustrierter Hartz-IV-Empfänger, der das Hobby entwickelt hat, Fahrzeuge in Brand zu stecken. Das hat der relativ lange Zeit gemacht. Wurde natürlich alles den linken Extremisten in die Schuhe geschoben in der Bildzeitung, wie da branden Autos. Irgendwann wurde dann dieser Mensch gefasst, weil sie ganz einfach gesagt haben, jedes Mal, wenn so eine Karre brennt, Funkzellenabfrage, das machen wir 3-4 Mal und schon haben wir den Typen. Genauso hat es natürlich dann auch geklappt. Letztendlich ist er dann noch durch irgendeine Überwachungskamera am Busbahnhof gelatscht und der Drops war gelutscht für ihn. Aber sie haben natürlich dann diesen etwas unschönen Beigeschmack, dass in dieser Funkzelle immer sehr, sehr viele Menschen sind, vor allem wenn du das in so einer großen Stadt wie Berlin machst. Und jetzt frage ich mich ausgerechnet, der Zoll im Rahmen welcher Ermittlung macht er denn so viele Funkzellen ab?
Der Zoll ist unter anderem zuständig für Verstöße gegen Exportvorschriften. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das damit was zu tun hat. Also irgendwie Waffenschieber zum Beispiel. Oder auch Verstöße gegen Embargovorschriften. Also wenn zum Beispiel irgendjemand auf den Gedanken kommt, dringend irgendwelche nuklearen Spaltmaterialien in Iran verschiffen zu müssen. Oder irgendwelche Zentrifugen oder so. Und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der Zoll da Funk-Sendabfragen macht. Frag mich jetzt nicht in welcher Situation ganz genau. Aber vielleicht wenn die, vielleicht tracken die irgendwelche Lieferungen, dass die ja irgendwie ein Handy platzieren oder irgendwie, ich weiß es nicht.
Das könnte es ja dann wieder mit her stillen SMS machen.
Ja, das ist uns vielleicht ganz interessant, wo wir gerade diese beiden Maßnahmen so separat besprechen. Also eigentlich ist ja die Maßnahme, die man eigentlich verwendet, um festzustellen, wer war wo oder genau, um welches Endgerät war wo, die Funk-Sendabfrage. Und die stille SMS löst doch, soweit ich das verstanden habe, das Problem, was mache ich, wenn die Leute ihr Handy gerade nicht aktiv einsetzen? Dann habe ich eben im Prinzip nur die Location Area. Und wenn ich aber das ein bisschen genauer wissen will, dann provoziere ich quasi Einträge für die Funkzellenabfrage, in die ich SMS schicke.
Genau, aber die stille SMS setzt voraus, dass du eine Zielperson hast, die du tracken möchtest. Die Funkzellenabfrage machst du ja in der Regel, oder so wie ich sie jetzt kenne, du willst einfach wissen, wer war alles zu dem Zeitpunkt da. Das heißt, das ist eine Massenmaßnahme, deren Sinn ich im Fall dieser Autobrenne oder den strategischen Sinn und Erfolg ich bei diesen Autobrennen dann sehe. Andererseits wurde da natürlich aus Datenschutzperspektive eine Menge Kollateralschaden angerichtet, weil bei jeder einzelnen dieser Funkzellenabfragen eben der Aufenthaltsort vieler Personen erfasst wurde. Und das eben Datum ist, was vielleicht erstmal nicht unbedingt so datenschutzmäßig in Ordnung ist.
Und da gibt es dann ja auch noch das große Problem, wie ist es eigentlich mit der Benachrichtigung dieser Leute? Das ist ja ein, wo wir gerade bei der Funkzellenabfrage sind, noch ein spannendes Thema. Eigentlich steht ja im Gesetz, dass alle Leute, die von der Funkzellenabfrage betroffen sind, benachrichtigt werden müssen davon hinterher. Da gibt es dann allerdings die Ausnahme, dass man nicht weiß, wer sich ja Inhaber verbirgt, und man nicht weiß, wer sich ja inhaber verbirgt, Wenn du eine bestimmte Nummer hast, dann muss man keine Bestandsdatenabfragen machen, nur um das rauszukriegen. Das kann man natürlich irgendwie verstehen. Außerdem kann man von der Benachrichtigung absehen, wenn davon auszugehen ist, dass die Leute kein Interesse haben. Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn jemand der Staatsanwaltschaft einen Fax schickt und sagt, Leute, ich hab hier die Nummer so und so und ich würde gerne benachrichtigt werden? Dann hat man den Inhaber zu der Nummer. Das heißt, man müsste keine Bestandsdatenabfragen machen. Und außerdem hat man das Interesse quasi schwarz auf weiß. Man kann also eigentlich nicht mehr davon ausgehen, dass der nicht benachrichtigt werden will. Eigentlich müssten die Staatsanwaltschaften, wenn sie sich ans Gesetz halten wollten, jedenfalls, wenn ihnen so ein Fax vorliegt, mal bei jeder Funkzellenabfrage hinterher die Daten scannen, ob da jemand erfasst worden ist, der sein Interesse bekundet hat. Ist ein interessanter Fall. Ein paar Leute haben das mal gemacht. Ich glaube, Michael Ebeling war einer von denen, der hier im AK-Vorrat aktiv war. Ich bin wirklich mal gespannt, ob da irgendwas bei rauskommt. Bislang ist mir nur bekannt, dass Staatsanwaltschaften sehr verschnupft reagieren und sagen, das ist nicht vorgesehen. Aber genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Es steht ja ausdrücklich im Gesetz, dass man benachrichtigen muss, es sei denn, man müsste eine Bestandsdatenabfrage machen, und es sei denn, man geht davon aus, der will nicht. Wenn jemand will, dann muss man und sagt, welche Nummern er so hat. Also das ist noch ein schöner Hack. Wenn man will, dass man da mal so ein bisschen Transparenz schafft, dann kann man ja mal so einen Fax schicken.
Es wäre natürlich auch eigentlich, also es ist natürlich für den Anbieter überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das ist für den Mobilfunkanbieter ja.
Ja, aber die Benachrichtigungspflicht, die trifft die Staatsanwaltschaft. Klar, der Mobilfunkanbieter könnte das, der darf es aber gar nicht. Der darf selbst nach Beendigung der Maßnahmen seine Kunden nicht darüber informieren. Der hat also so eine Art Gag-Order, wie es in den USA so schön heißt. Der hat einen Maulkorb, aber die Staatsanwaltschaft hat eigentlich die gesetzliche Pflicht zu benachrichtigen.
Das wäre ja auch noch schöner, du marschierst gerade so, hast gerade wieder so ein schönes Auto angezündet, gehst nach Hause, kriegst eine SMS. Sie sind gerade zur Zielperson einer Funkzellenabfrage geworden. Bringen Sie nächste Mal beim Auto an, ihr Handy nicht mit. Aber okay, ja, das ist also... Aber da, wie muss ich mir das jetzt vorstellen? Also die Sache ist doch, selbst wenn ich jetzt diesen Brief schreibe und dieses Interesse bekunde, dann kann ich also sagen, okay, wenn ich das nächste Mal zum Opfer oder Beifang einer Funkzellenabfrage werde, dann muss ich informiert werden. Wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann ist das ein eindeutiger Verstoß, für den ich euch vor ein Verwaltungsgericht dann zur Verantwortung ziehen kann, um euer Versäumnis dort höchstrichterlich verbriefen zu lassen. Aber dafür müsste ich ja erst einmal selber feststellen können, dass ich Ziel einer Funkzellenabfrage wurde. Das kann ich ja nicht, denn das ist ja ein reiner Datenabgriff beim Provider.
Ganz genau.
Im Gegensatz übrigens zur stillen SMS, kurz ein bisschen Eigenwerbung. Man kann natürlich bestimmte Mobilfunkgeräte so umprogrammieren, dass sie diese stillen SMS anzeigen. Das hört ja Richter natürlich jetzt ungern, aber da gibt es ein Open-Source-Tool, wo man zumindest alte Osmo.com-Telefone dazu bringen kann. Das verlinke ich dann auch mal.
Und das gute 6150 bestimmt auch, oder? Das gute alte Nokia war doch das Handy, das man wunderschön, wo man alle möglichen Tricks machen konnte.
Das weiß ich nicht, das ist mir dann schon fast zu alt.
Das ist in der Tat natürlich total alt. Ich glaube, das ist ein Handy, das ist 1997 vorgestellt worden. Das kann auch wirklich nur SMS, dann kann es noch irgendwie GPRS. Aber das ist ein großartiges Handy. Das hat nämlich quasi einen eingebauten Netzwerkmonitor. Der hat ein extrem cooles Feature. Das konnte man nämlich auf bestimmte Funkkanäle fest nageln. Und da gab es sehr schöne Use-Cases in Verbindung mit der O2-Homezone. Da konnte man also außerhalb der Homezone...
Ah, das Ding auf die Zelle nageln und nochmal ein bisschen weitergehen.
Dann konnte man auch mit zwei Strichen noch am anderen Ende der Stadt aus der Homezone telefonieren. Habe ich mal gehört, dass das Leute gemacht haben.
Aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Du musst schon, dass die Telefone relativ weit unter Kontrolle bringen, weil natürlich vermieden werden soll, dass Nutzer standardverletzende Dinge tun. Deswegen ist ja auch in einem modernen Telefon oder in jedem Telefon das Baseband getrennt von dem Hauptapplikationsprozessor. Das ist genau auf dem, wo diese Funkschnittstelle ist, dass da nicht irgendwelcher Unsinn auf einmal passiert. Zum Beispiel könntest du ja auf einmal anfangen, stille SMS zu versenden.
Das wäre ja nicht schön.
Geht übrigens auch nicht. Sperren deutsche Anbieter. Wenn ich jetzt versuche, eine stille SMS zu schicken, dann wird im Zweifelsfall gefiltert.
Und wie machen das dann die Polizeieinheiten, die quasi Spezial-SIM-Karten, wo das freigeschaltet ist?
Nee, die nutzen... Also es gibt sogenannte Large Accounts, die dann direkt an dem SMSC von den Providern hängen.
Die benutzen also gar kein Endgerät mehr, kein Handy, sondern das ist direkt eine Datenschnittstelle.
Also ich weiß nicht, wenn du so Online-Banking machst mit Transaktionsnummern, da sitzt jetzt auch keiner bei der Bank und tippt die SMS an dem iPhone. Also das ist ein automatisiertes Gateway, was da über ein Large-Account pro Minute oder Sekunde diese ganzen Nachrichten alle rausballert.
Ok, das ist irgendwie IP-basiert.
Ja, da gibt es dann, wie gesagt, das sind dann sogenannte Large-Accounts, die direkt an dem SMSC hängen. Und von den deutschen Strafverfolgungsbehörden sagt man zumindest nach, dass sie selber nicht so einen Large-Account haben, sondern irgendwelche Anbieter nutzen. Aber das ist Hörensagen. Also wie es funktioniert, ein normaler Nutzer kann eine stille SMS nicht versenden, wird gefiltert, Large-Accounts können sowas sehr wohl. Die können auch ganz andere Sachen noch verschicken. Also diese Konfigurations-SMS bei Roaming und so, die sollten einen normalen Nutzer eigentlich nicht versenden können. Und wenn ja alles vernünftig konfiguriert ist, können sie das auch nicht. Eben auch auf diese SIM-Karten-Schwächen, die ich da gerade kurz am Randeffekt habe.
Oder diese Programmier-SIMs, die es vorher bei O2 gab, wiederum für die Home-Zone. Das war ja ein ziemlich smartes Verfahren. Da gab es Register auf der SIM-Karte, wo die irgendwie die Mittelkoordinate und den Radius einprogrammiert haben. Und zwar over the air. Da gab es so eine OTA-SIM irgendwie, wo die das direkt in die SIM einprogrammiert haben.
Genau, das war dieser andere, das hatte ich gerade kurz am Rande erwähnt. Es gibt auch SMS-Nachrichten, die du an die SIM-Karte schreibst, über die der Nutzer auch nicht informiert wird. Darüber kannst du zum Beispiel so etwas machen, wie kleine Java-SIM-Applikationen mit Input füttern. Also zum Beispiel die SIM-Applikation, die dem Handy sagt, ja, das sieht jetzt aus wie die Homezone. Deswegen zeig mal dieses Häuschen da oben an. Aber auch Konfigurationseinstellungen, wie zum Beispiel, welches Netzwerk du beim internationalen Roman zu bevorzugen hast.
Da gibt es eine Prioritätenliste quasi.
Klar, da gibt es natürlich Netze, mit denen dein Mobilfunk-Anbieter kooperiert. Du kommst also, ich reise jetzt irgendwie in die USA, mein Handy geht an, meldet sich an, wird durch diese Netze durchgetunnelt. Landet also dann über SS7 bei meinem deutschen Anbieter. Der erkennt A, der Neumann ist gerade in den USA. Und dann schickt er eine binäre SMS, die der SIM-Karte sagt. Übrigens, du kannst dich jetzt mit allen Netzen verbinden. In Deutschland hast du ja quasi eine Blacklist, wo wir dir sagen, womit du dich nicht verbinden sollst. Und die Netze nehmen dich auch nicht an. Und hier in den USA gibt es jetzt mehrere Netze, die du nehmen kannst. Aber unser Roaming-Agreement ist am besten mit Sprint oder AT&T. Deswegen bevorzuge doch AT&T, wenn du ein Netz suchst. Und diese OTA-Kommunikation ist natürlich kryptographisch gesichert. Es wurde der Versuch unternommen, sie kryptographisch zu sichern, der in einigen Fällen auch missglückt ist.
Mit RC4 oder so?
Nein, das war DESS. Und zwar einfach DESSen. Da konntest du dann einen Non-Planetax-Angriff machen. Und dadurch den Schlüssel, mit dem die Nachrichten verschlüsselt. Und signiert werden, von dem Server, der die Kommandos gibt, und der SIM-Karte waren die gleichen. Das heißt, jede SIM-Karte hatte einen Key, und es war kein asymmetrisches Krypto-Verfahren dazwischen.
Ach, sondern ein Geheimer Schlüssel in allen SIM-Karten?
Nein, der war schon pro SIM-Karte anders. Aber das war der gleiche Schlüssel, mit dem der Server, der das Kommando gibt, verschlüsselt hat. Das heißt, die hatten keine unterschiedlichen. Und der Angriff funktioniert also dadurch, dass du der SIM-Karte ein Kommando zusendest, dieses Kommando nicht mit dem richtigen Schlüssel signierst, woraufhin die SIM-Karte dir dann eine SMS zurückschreibt, in der sie sagt, ich verweigere die Ausführung dieses Befehls mit der Begründung, dass du nicht korrekt signiert hast.
Ach so, das ist ein Non-Planetext.
Genau, diese Nachricht ist immer gleich. Einige SIM-Karten hatten eine Fehlkonfiguration, die darin resultierte, dass die SIM-Karte aber diese Nachricht signiert hat. Dann hattest du als Angreifer einerseits diese Nachricht, die immer gleich ist. Das ist eine wichtige Bedingung für einen Non-Planetxt, dass du Rainbow-Tables beschreiben konntest. Das war heutzutage mit Rainbow-Tables in einer brauchbaren Zeit zu knacken. Zumindest bei der Schlüssellänge, die da zum Einsatz kam. Ich glaube, das waren so 56 Bild. Das hast du 2 bis 6 Minuten gebraucht, um den Schlüssel zu knacken. Dieser Schlüssel, der ja eigentlich der der SIM-Karte war, den konntest du dann aber auch wieder nutzen, um der SIM-Karte dann Befehle zu geben, die korrekt signiert sind und die sie dann in Folge dessen auch ausführt. Und dann konntest du halt so Scherze machen, wie auf die SIM-Karte dann eine kleine Java-Applikation installieren, was wenige wissen. SIMs sind Java, VMs. Und da konntest du dann zum Beispiel so eine einfache Applikation reinschreiben. Schreib mir doch mal alle 5 Minuten eine SMS an folgende Nummer und sag, in welcher Zelle du gerade eingeloggt bist. Oder schick doch mal 20 SMS an folgende Premium-SMS-Nummer, wo ich dann nachher pro SMS 5,90 Euro gut geschrieben kriege. Und ähnliche Angriffsszenarien, die dann da möglich wurden.
Sehr schön.
Präsentiert von Carsten Nohl bei der OM letzten Jahres im Sommer und beim 30C3 letzten Jahres. Und Carsten Nohl, wie ich ja schon mal erwähnt habe, mein Arbeitgeber.
Ja, das war quasi jetzt noch eine Runde Handy-Nerds.
Ja, wenn du mich einmal, wenn du schon noch nachfragst.
Ich habe mich mit dieser Auto-Home-Zone in der Tat mal intensiver beschäftigt und fand das damals super spannend. Und ja, freut mich sehr zu hören, wie das weitergegangen ist in den letzten 14, 15 Jahren.
So, damit sind wir jetzt am Ende einer rekordlangen Sendung. Ich hoffe aber, dass wir den Bedarf an juristischer Experteneinschätzung der Hörerinnen zumindest aus dem defizitären Bereich rausgeholt haben, indem wir jetzt hier einen kompetenten Menschen zu diesen Themen zugestanden sind. Und es bleibt mir natürlich an dieser Stelle noch dem Benjamin zu danken, der natürlich genau weiß wofür. Und ganz besonders natürlich bei Ulf.
Sehr gerne, es wäre mir eine Freude. Und vielleicht auch bald mal.
Ja, ich hoffe, jetzt ist es ja nicht mehr so weit.
In der Tat. Richtig, genau. Jetzt müssen wir uns nicht mehr über den Atlantik verabreden.